[Music]
it's Monday we're here it's July 17th
and it's all happening now on the H3
podcast
we are here
um a week
of subpar shows last week has led us to
this week we've put all of our minds
together to bring you the best shows
possible and I think you're really gonna
like the shows we have for you guys this
week All Aboard that sounds just like
Olivia right you hear it I hear it thank
you today's episode is sponsored by
honey
and gamersup who we love love love love
our sponsors
all right how's everybody doing Zach is
back in the house hello everybody
thank you thank you very much thank you
thank you Olivia did a great job but I
always miss Zach when he's gone so
Olivia did fantastic yeah it's nice to
see you thank you welcome back thank you
um how was the wedding very hot uh very
very hot uh you know we showed up at 1
45 and had to be dressed by 2 45 for
pictures and um it was a lot there was
some groomsmen drama that went on but oh
really tell me about it uh without
getting too much detail people tried to
steal others coats because they didn't
try their suit on
um if one person even tried stealing the
groomsmen coat so I mean the uh why
because of it groom's coat because it
fit them better correct well I wouldn't
say better it was a little somebody
tried to steal the groom's outfit it was
a little too small uh even the group so
the person that stole the groom's coat
the coat was too big on him and uh I
think I'm not this is not proven I think
he might have sneakily kind of Taken
someone else's jacket which happened to
be the groom's coat did he know he was
taking the groom's call I can't answer
that question D is he the type of person
that would take the groom's coat
yes wow
and what is his name yeah sure Jack
Lewis Zach Lewis but uh it was a whole
debacle and but it all got figured out
uh but yeah it was it was a good time
yeah
it's a little bit of drama yeah my
brother got married at the same spot in
the summer and I don't know if you
remember when I was in that full
Chewbacca yeah I was wearing that Zach
um on my day like that day I I don't you
almost passed out right I was bad yeah
it was the hottest I've ever been I
think it was crazy
um it was it was very very warm it was
very warm beautiful yeah welcome back
everybody have a good weekend
yeah yeah definitely
I watched fousey stream all weekend okay
right so Friday
we ended our show by interacting with
fouseytubes live
and uh it was a journey actually I think
that we may have saved his life and
career which he's speed running he's
trying to ruin it don't get me wrong but
we definitely did
yeah he was going to go through TSA
checkpoint at the airport with his text
to voice donations on
I which is not a good idea considering
people do a bomb threat no matter where
he goes
[Music]
but um you've been you've been following
his Antics yeah I was just tuning in you
know you know real quick and uh I was
just hooked and before I knew it I was
several hours in and then I was back the
next day and I couldn't get enough
so maybe he has a good product I mean I
should I was I was glued too no
sincerely like if he doesn't get banned
I think he's really onto something
because
it was the most inner it was like
watching a live version of Jersey Shore
with just the situation if that's like
just the best character just the best
character yeah
okay that's pretty that's pretty
exciting but he needs I I don't know
fousey he just
he skirts too close to Danger every time
like
um this is the clip when he got out okay
you guys are gonna you guys are gonna
love this
so we got him to turn off his stream
when he got in the airport we said it's
going to ruin your life you're going to
get banned so as soon as he lands at the
airport in I guess Texas Houston
wherever he was going Yep this is what
happened the VOD purposes for all the
people to see the content we just got
just Landing text from Mom when are you
bombing the Air Force
right now
Allahu Akbar
that is such a bad idea
did someone respond to him or is that
unrelated I
don't know I think it was someone
responding I just couldn't make out what
he was saying
man nobody even turned around they're
like please God please God please God
that's what's up yeah so imagine he did
that through TSA checkpoint not good
we are here for vibes
but he's at 14 000 Subs 18 18 000 yeah
oh yeah well actually I talked to fousey
I texted with him a little bit we had a
nice chat and uh he's coming in on
Wednesday which I'm very excited
actually you know I've been trying to
get [__] in here
um to talk to him because he is an
interesting guy he's been through all
kinds of craziness
in his career
and uh well I look forward to seeing him
on Wednesday it'll be nice gay we'll see
if he makes it here he said he was super
excited to come in he's like he never
thought in a million years he would get
so much love from the H3 fam that's the
thing yeah that's the thing people
they don't understand how the the
community works it's like
yes we can be psychotic freaks
okay yes you can be embarrassed to be a
part of this community sometimes yes
it's hard to tell your friends and
family that you watch this podcast but
if there's somebody we like that comes
on we ride so hard for them oh yeah like
then it's the best they're the best I
truly think they're we're the best I
think you guys are the best but
clearly misunderstood he said something
along the lines of keemstar is going to
be mad as hell but if he actually cares
about me then he'll understand he
doesn't
but don't worry I don't care I'm not
even gonna ask him about keemstar I
really don't give a [__] it's like what
what am I gonna ask him how was the beef
jerky yes I want to ask him so many I
just don't care about him anymore oh you
can what do you want to ask him about
Keem
well I specifically I want to ask him
about the keemstar FouseyTUBE movie that
was deleted yeah
a tastes like beef jerky I have many
questions I would like to know why he
erased it
you know what that what you're talking
about Dan imagine that for 16 hours
straight that is what his stream is like
and it's just gold that's awesome yeah
yeah that sounds pretty good content
that sound that Lit that legit does
sound like good content also I want to
say congratulations to us this is our
fourth Colleen Ballinger video in a row
you know I realize if you don't include
the live show it's actually the fifth
if you don't include the live show yeah
what do you mean because the one just
prior to the live show was the original
oh lean PowerPoint so if you don't
include so we could say five out of six
five out of six yeah
[Music]
um so that's pretty exciting
uh but I gotta say I I fully ex I fully
expected not to be talking about it but
there yet again was another clip
that came to my attention that was so
goddamn
crazy I mean we all saw it and we're
like what the hell what the hell
what good thank you Zach and uh so well
you know at this point I gotta put her
in the title if I can sure
you gotta and then I've been wanting to
talk about this James this is like a a
blast from the past gossip uh headline
but what can you do it's rewind they
don't come around that often like I
we've been good for a long time doing
like sketches and bits in the title you
know don't deny it look at our tiles
there's always like uh we play this game
this person eats the spicy chip we do
this it's not click babe
and this isn't clickbait either but I'm
saying we haven't drama farmed in a long
time
okay the other thing is James Charles is
trying this Redemption Arc which we
haven't really dug into which is just
so crazy to me that is some [__]
it's really something
oh he's dropping like a new makeup line
it's like nobody better [__] buy that
please God
but um
what can I say so that's all coming up
here today we've got lots of fun stuff
to talk about I asked foosi you know
my thing with foosi is I just want to
make sure he's like okay
because we spoke about
he is bipolar
and um he has gone through manic
uh periods that have resulted in some
really bad
situations for him on YouTube
specifically the Drake
uh Greek meltdown
meltdown situation
um and uh he he I talked with him
briefly he said he's been on his his
medication he's been really good
he doesn't think he's having a manic
episode
but I I do care about him you know I
want to keep an eye on him I always
cared I always felt bad for fousey when
everybody was ganging up on him
keemstar was like legit trying to get
him to unalive himself
well he was saying that happened on July
15th with Drake and now uh he hit 15K
Subs on July 15. oh God don't get into
the numerology please he was just saying
it it meant a lot how far he's coming
okay good good good
um you know and I ran into fousey once
in real life I was just we were walking
in Encino just randomly getting a coffee
or something and I
he just came back I think it was right
after he got his ass beat and the boxing
match and his face was all [__] up he
just came back from surgery we had a
very uh Pleasant interaction that's how
we that's how we got each other's phone
numbers
stayed in touch
so he's coming on Wednesday also just
for the record because I was like yo
just so you know the gay sound bite like
if that if that does bother you like
we'll stop it you know what I mean like
it's it's fine
um
and he said quote he said quote well
hold on Zach
he said no I was just 100 kidding thank
you though
so that's cool so he doesn't mind it and
I don't think he should it's just funny
you know yeah I felt worthless
I feel ugly
I felt gay and I wonder how he feels now
he's come a long way and that's
inspiring okay
I should ask him about his sexuality
not deeply I just want to know if maybe
no
we'll feel it out you okay
so let's take a look at uh well we'll
get into all that but right now I want
to I want to show you guys something I
saw this last night on Tick Tock and you
know that I am so anti-chiropractor I
would destroy this whole business if I
could they these people are charlatans
and they are hurting people look at this
okay and Sam you said you're you you're
into chiropractor despite all of my
groundwork all of mine no no no no no no
no Sam's anti I hate oh what's that
Olivia yeah Olivia is Pro because they
[__] up your Dad's life right yes well
not his life but his back
but yeah you only have one back one back
one life one God yeah
that is true
so I guess yeah his life and so you know
I've been I've been doing a lot of work
to uh
destroy this profession but here here
watch this so here's a little story time
on how I ended up like this
and on constant watch
three days ago I went to the
chiropractor because I had ringing in my
ear
and I didn't have medical insurance so I
didn't want to go you know spend money
on a doctor's visit I figured
100 to the Cairo let them adjust a few
things
maybe get rid of the pressure for a
ringing in his ear no that happened
after well the chiropractor he had back
pain he went to the Cairo and he said he
he kind of went out of order he says
I've had ringing in my ears so I came to
the doctor gotcha he's going back in
time gotcha gotcha is that what he said
whatever whatever and later on I ended
up with a splitting headache yeah
headache went from like my temples all
the way down around my ears into the
bottom of my neck couldn't take it
anymore so I took ibuprofen and went to
bed
the next day I woke up and
I had the worst dizzy spells like I felt
loopy I feel like I couldn't focus or
concentrate on anything when I looked
around
um so me being me I panicked and I
decided I'm gonna go to the walking
because something's not right I don't
feel right
so I went to the walk-in and they didn't
have anybody available so they sent me
to the emergency room
I went to the emergency room
and told them all of my symptoms ear
ringing pressure in the back of my head
but now I feel really dizzy you know
I've got a little bit of tingling in my
fingers my tongue was a little tingly at
the time and he immediately wanted to do
a CT scan
[Music]
boy was I glad he did that in the CT
scan he found that the chiropractor
when he was aligning or whatever they do
when they work on your neck he actually
ruptured
um what they call dissecting it I guess
yeah we're going to do a simple uh neck
dissection here for you
dissected my cargo artery in my neck on
the left side
I thought I was gonna go and maybe get
some medicine audio is super low and
immediately was thrown in an ambulance
and rushed to the medical center to be
treated where I'm at now
I'm not allowed to leave I've been stuck
with needles about 20 times
the two different IVs for different
fluids including blood thinners I
[Music]
can't even remember how many tests they
brought on me so far I have someone in
here every two hours making sure that
I'm okay I can't even get out of the bed
to pee I have bands on me that say fall
risk and if I get up from the bed it
sends off an alarm and that's because
the damage the chiropractor did to my
neck was so severe that I can have a
blood clot which can you know cause a
stroke or kill me
so my 100 chiropractor appointment
has now turned into thousands and
thousands of dollars of medical bills
and the worst part is they said that if
they don't do surgery to repair the
artery I'll have to take a blood thinner
for the rest of my life and if I don't
take it
I could have a stroke
so
that's the thing we did it that's the
kind of adjustment I'm talking about
baby we did it I he's like yo I severed
your [__] main artery from your brain
to your spine
now that's an adjustment now what
happened to your dad Sam in my quest to
discredit this whole profession he went
for sciatica and they just made it 20
times worse that's the only time I've
ever seen him cry almost after that it
was like horrific so what is sciatica
um it's when you have it's
your sciatic nerve is like pinched where
is that like below your butt cheek kind
of up below the butt cheek yeah that
like that's where you feel that's where
you would feel like sciatic pain like
kind of it's like where your bottom of
your butt cheek and your leg meet oh
okay I I see what you're saying yeah but
it's not so painful it hurts so bad to
have that
and so he went in there to see if it
would help and the dude made it way
worse oh yeah that's what's up
that's what's up what's up that's what's
up baby
shout out to the profession so I I don't
know guys it's just not worth it like
I'm telling you be careful these
chiropractors man was it worth all
they're not doctors
okay
they literally go to like a four-year
College like that's what I did
and I don't know [__] about anything
to become an MD what is it like 12 Years
baby yep 12 years plus residency or no
including residency if you specialize
okay I am I have a surgeon
there it is he is a surgeon in a sense I
mean he severed his main artery I mean
cut that [__] wide open
so there that is
a couple more things here at the top of
the show thank you
is it the pizza curse or is it the gas
leak in my basement this is where we
shot Frenemies in the basement
was filmed at Ethan's basic basement was
the pizza curse really a gas leak curse
um
or maybe the pizza curse caused my pipes
to rupture
that makes more sense that feels more
like
that's more in line with what I saw
because I don't think
it's been cursed down there since we
moved in
something happened
[Music]
and this is like the hottest week of the
year we have no AC this week would you
bring the um
the baby carriage down there that's why
we don't talk about that dude that's
when we first opened it
first of all that Carriage I
I'm telling you don't talk about that
anymore
I don't want to hear about the baby
carriage
we burned that thing we released the
curse right Zach did we burn it we give
it to Oliver tree we gave it to Oliver
tree right it's his problem now yeah
[__] him that's how that [__] Works Dan
I transferred it to Oliver
and
and his life has kind of been [__] since
we did that he's been complaining yeah
it's falling apart yeah
he's like been in hiding
yeah
the curse
what if Trisha caused the gas leak on
her way out and was like this will teach
him
wait she did PL she did cosplay as this
character
in that video she was playing
the Black Widow is that what her name
Debbie Debbie
oh [__] holy [__] it all makes sense now
playing the long game
because your house didn't blow up and
that was like two years ago it did not
know
ugly
that's something ever in a minute
[Music]
um let's see another big brain uh Pearl
take
I think we should probably stop talking
about her because she's just like
literally
such an attention clout Goblin like
genuinely I don't she can't be serious
at this point the stuff she's tweeting
out is so so demented I mean look at
this mm-hmm what we got what we got it
says just pearly things I'm really
starting to wonder if there was more to
the story of Brock Turner Weinstein R
Kelly and all those other profile sex
assault cases I'm not saying there was
or wasn't but it could be worth visiting
yeah this is just engagement bait this
is stupid
apparently she also was saying we need
to look again at Larry Nasser that's the
guy who like essayed every Olympic you
know what keep going Pearl because this
is you know this is making your side
look real good
Larry Nasser is like never alone
incarnate never change Pearl I mean what
the [__] on my work phone call me Larry
Nasser
okay Pearl go ahead
yes go camping with all these guys you
mentioned have a good time just you and
them okay Pearl Weinstein R Kelly and
Larry Nassar walk into a tent
[Music]
what's the chances
she comes out of there
um she's the worst
he's the worst okay absolutely the worst
actually she's not even the worst which
makes her the worst because she's just
not the best at anything so true very
mediocre in terms of life she's just
like aggressively mediocre at everything
in her life that must suck I don't think
she's mediocre which is bad here's
another one that got got me uh going
thank God for men because I can't do
this it's lit you just literally put it
there I had I had a responsibility
I also
I'm not gonna do that but it's not
because I'm a girl I just don't want to
and I will have my other friend do it
for me usually a girl
I think Pearl just doesn't like to build
do you think she's just lazy yeah she's
dying what is she doing stacking planks
I mean it's not even building it's just
putting slats yeah it's a slot it's just
like I get it I get why you don't want
to do it I'm unhelpless so this is
literally like Legos for one plus I'm an
idiot busy work oh this is Lego Duplo
let me hear you say well wayo
yeah she's such a [__] I said nah
you're just dumb also no man L it's like
who's gonna build that for you single
dumbass
you better figure it out because ain't
no man coming to help you
kind of cause gray using R1 right now
people have been saying yo what's for
the deal you're using Twitter okay I
would be on threads 100 of the time if
they had a news feed that's the reason I
come I don't I'm not really reading
people's tweets I like to just see
uh because I I need to know what's going
on for this show right it's important so
thread needs to add something like that
and then I'm gonna be there all the time
I got no reason to come to Twitter
they'll get there they'll get there I
hope so
I saw that they're losing their
hemorrhaging users yeah not surprising I
think the hype is definitely over but
I'm going back there as soon as they add
a news feed I love it
you're still there oh hell yeah what do
you talk about there uh I don't know I'm
not as like R-rated I guess as Twitter
but I'm not even that R-rated on Twitter
what do you post on Twitter it's R-rated
I don't know Jesus every photo you post
says like inappropriate and then you
have to plus press on blur and then it's
just you yeah that's click bait he's
trying to sell tickets ah yeah right I
don't know what you're talking about
because I always click that [__] I'm
like what is Zach doing I've got you to
click though yeah every time
so um then let's see
James Charles reveals that his brother
cut contact with him following child
grooming allegations vibes
Little Prince
you know love that for him
and then RFK Jr okay
what is wrong with this guy
uh I mean I know he's an anti-vaxxer
conspiracy theorist and he's been on
jail Rogue and we've talked about all
this the Jews but like
so this was leaked from a meeting he had
with a bunch of I don't know who these
are
I mean [__] this looks more uh
this looks more secret society than
anything the Jews are involved in that I
know of straight Bohemian Grove [__] he
goes kovid was F made
to ethnically spare Jews
he says
covid was engineered to spare Chinese
people and Ashkenazi Jews only Jews
I was like holy [__]
you know
so new anti-Semitism just dropped
I don't think you can engineer viruses
to ethnically Target people that seems a
little bit uh sci-fi insane
no it's not that's not I don't believe
that that is possible
the Jew killer just a [__] virus that
affects but we are but we are a bunch of
Jews so
well I got Coke I don't have a lot of
credibility on this one do we I got
kovid oh [__] and you're 99.99 yeah dude
I don't want that you're Giga Jew look
it
has done nothing for me
literally all I get from that is death
threats weird conspiracy [__] and now
apparently I have created covid to spare
my Jewish Brothers
I got coveted dumbass Shalom brother
shalom kovid was us baby we did it
he's scary
I mean
yeah and I saw a lot of people being
like this makes sense
Twitter lately has genuinely been just
like people straight up calling openly
just verified like yeah we need to we
need a solution to the Jewish problem
that makes sense like if you look at the
response to this it's like yeah
the Nazis were right straight up on
Twitter verified that's what I see every
day on Twitter now is it just my face in
the Nazis do you is that what you guys
see or is it just my feed I don't go on
Twitter anymore
I'm out are you out I'm out when did
that happen when we talked about it a
couple weeks ago I didn't know you were
out oh dude
you're on threads yeah the superior like
you don't read tweet tweeters
well I mean if people still tweet or
link tweets on Reddit all the time if
there's something interesting going on
or whatever sure but no I don't like
open the app and browse anymore doc I'm
not clicking this
it's too risky
oh [__] oh wow that's great Zach Lewis
live San Diego August 19. just inside
wow congratulations I know right isn't
that amazing that's a huge spot wow that
must have been expensive ah no the
company paid for it oh
which company are you talking Spotify
about the talent right what talent will
do for you it's true
um can we find the video of this one of
of uh RFK Jr yeah
kova 19 attacks certain races
disproportionately he said at a recent
dinner in New York City the remarks were
videotaped and first
uh uh published by the New York Post on
Saturday kova 19 is targeted to attack
Caucasians and black people
hmm the people who are most immune are
Ashkenazi Jews and the Chinese the [__]
it's so insane he continued adding we
don't know whether it was deliberately
targeted or not but there are papers out
there that show the racial or ethnic
differential and impact
I'm not saying the Jews made this virus
to kill black people and white people
but what I am saying
is that there are papers out there
which I will not provide to you now
or ever
that suggests that Jews are behind this
whole thing
go watch the video by the way yeah am I
Jewish I'm not
I wish I you know what it's like
the only thing being Ashkenazi Jews got
me
is death threats conspiracy theories and
a bunch of [__] genetic disorders
like what's so great about this and I
got coveted I don't want it take it I
don't [__] want it
so sick of this [__]
you know I mean you do have a nice
hairline that is true okay but that well
lots of Jews are balding too it's not
like a Super G yeah uh that doesn't seem
Ashkenazi at all to be honest that's a
that's I have the rare mutation there
yeah yeah
you know
I'm just a freak of nature in that way
and we need to talk about bio weapons
but whoever I know a lot now about Bible
okay at what point can I make fun of his
voice because he's because he's saying
he wants to kill Jews I think it's game
honoring I'm still I'm still holding off
I'm holding off
gears and um
uh and you know what we the technology
that we now have all these
we have we've put hundreds of millions
of dollars into uh ethnically targeted
micros this guy has no idea what he's
talking about he has no credentials he
has no research this is psychotic freak
[__] ethnically targeted viruses
I am Jewish
don't say anything in fact
[Music]
exactly targeted open 19 attacks certain
races
[Music]
the races that are most of you are
immune to the government data are
because of the of the structure of the
genetic structure
dude the genetic structure targets other
ethnicities like do you under that
that's insane
we're all humans you dumb ass we are all
the same species
oh no Jesus got the matzo ball soup so
they're immune man have you ever heard
of a virus that just affects like
brown-haired people
or like one specific breed of dog it
doesn't exist it's insane it's so stupid
you can fact check that AB yeah thank
you
no that's my understanding as well that
that that you know
how's that like if you understand how
viruses work even a little bit that
doesn't make any sense
it's just a fact in my opinion right
I mean you could probably Target people
with like
rare genetic um
disorders or anomalies but a whole
ethnic group
I don't know and maybe even that doesn't
happen I don't know I don't know
anything about it
genetic differentials among different
races
of The receptors of the H2 receptor
um code 19 is targeted to attack uh
Caucasians and and
black people
it's crazy at least I like what he's
doing he's trying to bring the blacks
and the whites together uh to kill the
Jews
solidarity at long last well against a
common enemy that's never happened
before has it order to comprehend you're
gonna have to break some right
comprehend in order to comprehend to eat
the uh the omelet of knowledge you're
gonna need to break right those
eggshells and in this the omelet of
knowledge in this case is Ashkenazi Jews
uh no there's no inherent connection
between a specific race or ethnicity and
susceptibility to a particular virus
virus can affect people of any race or
ethnicity and their their impact is
determined by various factors such as
individual immune responses Access to
Health Care living conditions and
genetic
predispositions however certain social
and economic factors can uh contribute
to disparities and the impact of viruses
among different populations for example
socioeconomic factors including access
to health care I don't think that's
ethnic education and living conditions
yeah I don't think that's what he's
talking about
you're asking for the virus
right
apparently I'm not as an Ashkenazi Jew
well which one of you guys didn't catch
the virus
okay now now we have to ask why love is
Swedish and Swedish people are like
super secluded we don't really never did
lockdown right you have to ask yourself
why is that right right you gotta ask
that I there's papers in anything
so we we're maxed out on cameras until
we do our studio rework which is why I
have this awful wide shot over here yeah
let me see his love shot he has one
pixel
so when it crops into love
that's a pretty good solution though
yeah I like it but it's just for today
you have the I have papers that suggest
the Swedish are not as targeted as black
and white people and you have to ask
yourself why is that you gotta ask it at
least I have papers the Aryan race
Superior my friend whoa oh what color
your eyes love blue that's a problem oh
God damn it Superior that's a big
problem do you think your race is
superior no okay I don't you would say
that I would say that right
and a b says you and Lena both did not
catch the virus correct curious that's
interesting
very curious
I haven't gotten it either
but I'm half Ashkenazi what does that
mean I don't know but I have papers to
discuss it should ask RFK he'll know
he will I got papers on papers some
genetic disorders are more likely to
occur among people who Trace their
ancestry to a particular geographical
yeah I know that example of genetic
conditions that are more common in
particular groups sickle cell disease
yes more common African Americans and
everything that's wrong with me for
example
Ashkenazi Jews
dude I got so many problems I have to
play this every time he says
the Tourette's runs in my family OCD
runs my family colitis horrible stomach
stuff
just irritable bowels constantly just
acid reflux toilets getting all the time
I'm Ashkenazi and I I don't have like
any of these problems well as both of
your parents full Ashkenazi yeah really
your mom and dad both are yeah yeah I
need to get you you have you taken
ancestry test I haven't done like the
23andMe you didn't so we got to get a
breakdown because I don't believe you've
got that purebred like me I have stomach
issues but I don't got that 99.3 stomach
issues that's definitely I got stomach
problems we have to submit a DNA I'm
serious okay I'm down Ian can you take
care of that
is Ian collect his DNA is there is there
anybody else who we didn't test I
haven't taken it but I don't want them
having my [__] same here jeans bro I
didn't want to say that but yeah I'm the
same they already pretty much I I know
my dad took it I have his results so I
know at least 50 of my you're in there
already yeah
you're there I haven't taken it I would
love to okay yeah let's do it okay you
and you and Lena want to do it anyone
who wants to talk to Ian okay Ian Ian
I'm gonna give you some ideas my DNA do
you need a semen sample or what do you
need
okay now now RFK explained this zero
cases in North Korea
that's very very sus
zero not one hmm
I feel like RFK would think Koreans are
pretty much
just Chinese people
he doesn't see the difference yeah like
all Asians are just Chinese yeah like
he's of that generation and so he he did
say that then he said the Chinese
exactly yeah exactly
hmm
that China was covering up their covet
number so I thought that was the yeah I
don't understand it either and like
China has pretty much destroyed their
economy
in shutdowns and crazy preventative
measures
they definitely seem to be afraid of
covet there like deathly afraid it's all
theater man it's almost like it's a
deadly man
but he know is this covid related
I'm getting sidetracked but that's what
it is yeah
um we got to do our ads soon before we
move on to any new topics here okay
so we have two ads let me uh thank them
and then we'll get into all the good
stuff like the Colleen stuff the food
see stuff the James Charles stuff
also Ryan Cavanaugh made a new YouTube
channel guys this is very exciting
this is so fun that he did this
is this now is this possibly really him
these were just uploaded oh God Mr Beast
come on
why is he collabing with Ryan you don't
want that you don't want that are you
serious we gotta warn him Ryan
Cavanaugh's do something important
Embrace failure and live freely okay I'm
glad he's embracing his failures that's
all he's got at this point here's my
dude
so we gotta watch these Hollywood
producer I wonder if he included the one
the Habitat for Humanity one
can you look at Discord real quick Ethan
sure
gracias allegedly yeah I mean I was
saying I don't know if he made this
he may have I don't know right it could
just be a fan I don't know who else
would do this
it also has some kind of deep cut
interviews with him that I've never seen
before in fact a lot
you know sweet so look for it there's
the episode no he's a good guy he he's
super he's a force of nature
[Music]
all right thank you thank you to our
wonderful sponsors honey I love honey I
love it on toast I love it on Peanut
Butter I love it on in tea but that's
not the honey I'm talking about
I'm talking about a honey that's even
better
because it saves you money
money
today's episode is sponsored by PayPal
honey the easy way to save when shopping
on your iPhone or computer
ah I love them it's so easy takes two
seconds to install it on your browser
free to use and as you surf the website
as you shop
uh the internet
from clothes to food
Furniture you don't have to think about
it dude everything
as you go to checkout to buy it here's
what it does
[Music]
it says yo let me scour the internet for
the best promo code available for this
site you say cool click it takes like
five seconds boom look at all these
savings cheers these are all bona fide
authentic savings that we've made here
Bonafide honestly I don't I don't use a
lot of extensions but this is the one
probably that I
I use
across the board
like if I'm reinstalling a browser if I
got a new computer it's honey
you know
and that's what that is
yeah you know what else honey finds
deals
[Music]
so fast
love ya imagine you're shopping at one
of your favorite sites so when you check
out the honey button appears and all you
have to do is Click apply coupon boom
boom boom wait a few seconds honey
automatically applies it
you magically watch the price drop
it's obscene
guess what honey doesn't just work on
desktops now either it works on your
iPhone too just activate it on Safari on
your phone and you can save on the go
that's huge
you know
how much money you think you've saved
with honey Dan
me personally yeah
honest answer probably
two three hundred bucks there it is
effortless yeah without really having to
do anything yeah it is really it really
is that good give it a shot you know you
got nothing to lose getting honey only
takes a few seconds and by getting it
you'll be doing your self-assault and
supporting the show thank you get PayPal
honey for free at joinhoney.com h3tv
that's joinhoney.com
H3 give it a shot you got nothing to
lose and if you don't like it you can
uninstall it
it's that easy
thank you guys
you're getting food Sam what are you
thinking
I'm at 197 by the way I'm not sure
oh nice
thank you I don't know what do you want
I don't want fast food I can't do that
anymore I don't sorry love yeah I don't
either you eat any Taco Bell this
weekend uh no but I've had in and out in
and out I [__] love in and out thank
you oh interesting I love in and out
interesting in and out it's so legit
it's simple bro it's so so cheap too is
it dude yeah most places yeah I can
drink their spread like this spread is
so crazy dude you are American I add
that sauce extra two spreads on the
burger you're a sauce man yeah I love
the sauce yeah he's Saucy tell me about
a saucy guy goddamn uh thank you to
gamer Subs I hit this like it's the
nectar alive baby
Gamers up man
uh we got our new flavor coming out I'm
so excited
oh yeah spicy Margarita is the flavor
but we called it
Sigma brain
I don't care that they know okay I want
to shout it from the rooftop so
hopefully that was cool
but until then there's so many great
flavors to try I hit the black cherry
you guys with the mango you should dance
on that blue rash baby the Pina Colada
is amazing
here's the thing no sugar
so if you're hitting Sodis is a great
way to lose weight because it tastes
great it's got caffeine in it you can
get some without caffeine if that's not
your jam but it's hydrating it tastes
amazing it's got no calories
and what do you want more do you want
what do you want yeah what's dude you're
being unreasonable
love their cups too they're shakers and
as love said last time their powder is
dissolves better and it stays to salt
for a
like pretty much all the time it's nice
yeah unlike their lead filled
competitors
that's a joke no it's not a joke they
did have lead in it a negligible amount
but there was lead in it yeah I don't
think it was really all different
flavors all different flavors of lead
not theirs
did you know the Romans used to put lead
in their wine because they thought it
tasted good isn't that crazy
don't knock it till you try it they got
a point well taste test next episode
lead baby
is that I'm gonna fact check that no it
is yeah fact check me it's real romance
but lead maybe lead toes taste good
gives it a nice twang of mental illness
I'll try it
yeah I love the cups love the art
and um ours is coming out soon we got
our own cup we got our own flavor I'm
very excited but go to gamersups.gg and
use code H3 to get 10 off your order
thank you so much to gamer Subs we love
you please uh consider supporting our
wonderful sponsors thank you guys
yes it is believed that the ancient
Romans used to add lead to their wine
LED in the form of lead acetate was used
as a sweetener the addition of lead to
Wine was a common practice in ancient
Rome and other civilizations isn't that
nuts lead that's like the craziest thing
you can put in your body
well I mean we only
realize that lead is a problem like 40
50 years ago right I think it was longer
than that maybe it was long maybe like
80. yeah
but I think there was a whole bunch of
mental illness and and uh problems from
all the lead consumption like now that
they're studying it in retrospect yeah
so lead is delicious I mean maybe it is
good it must be
that is sweet it's why people ate lead
paint chips interesting
why it's why they named it Led Zeppelin
man right wait people ate lead chips
because it tasted good
I mean according to this random chapter
that cannot be that cannot be true
indulge girl treat yourself Thursday
introduce yourself Monday with the lead
chips
all right well now that that's done
let's see we got uh
is Tate really still posting I'm so
bored of him just go to jail already
idiot Gotti
Bugatti
14 minutes Jesus man welcome to another
episode of the tape show sweaty bald
shiny domed
the world's basically to take show at
the moment isn't it it's kind of like I
don't care
I don't
the shtick is up dude
[__] you're going to jail you're bum
you're [__] bum hey guys remember how
Andrew Tate sent me a cease and desist I
mean that was I don't think people
appreciated how epic that was that is
pretty epic he sent me and then
immediately dipped and we never heard
from him again and I said no [__] you
and he didn't do [__]
yeah that's what happened with Colleen's
but to be fair actually it wasn't as bad
Colleen's lawyer was like stop saying
this thing you're not saying about me
All Aboard he's like stop saying that
she put this on CD Baby I was like I
didn't say that
[__] me right yeah
but Andrew Tate Sims are still out there
I posted five uh annotate tick tocks
last week all of them got removed
and I appealed it and they didn't come
back I guess they just have a policy
they're done with him
oh yeah but that's so silly because
we're like uh proving him wrong I agree
but I think right they're just out on
the table none of it none of it
hey speaking of CD Baby I gotta say uh
it's still sitting in the uh the queue
it's still being inspected is it
possible that they've
reacted to the situation with Colleen I
get a pause on all that you know
it's a good point maybe especially if
her lawyers were contacting people yeah
yeah
that's not very interesting is it
so let's see um let's talk about fousey
yes so
congratulations to fousey Friend of the
show he is very excited about his 18 000
subs and heck that's pretty good you're
a piece of [__] hey stop I'm trying to
praise you bro 18 000 subscribers number
10 English speaking channel is that
right I mean 18 000 is a lot
I I'm not sure which uh chart he's
actually using because they break it
down so much by like live streaming and
uh I don't know I was I wasn't able to
find it but
I believe him
okay yeah it's probably it's probably
true I believe it 25 in the world all in
17 days I've been Live 24 7 on my twitch
and support has been insane I have no
intention of stopping or letting up we
seven we G7 what does that mean uh that
is uh his followers G7 I'm I'm actually
G7 it's uh his supporters well why is it
G7 G7 because it's game seven you're
down to seven and uh you think there's
nothing left
um pull it off most people give up but
you keep moving forward C7 baby it's
like a Last Dance type thing is that a
phrase or is that a original fousey it's
a model I don't know uh
but you identify with G7 yeah got it got
it uh he says I haven't drank in two
years so they brought this sign out with
water and Red Bull that's nice he just
he just tweeted at me actually I must be
watching oh he's a good guy I like
fousey I want I don't I want the best
for him you know
probably don't scream Allah Akbar
airports though yeah
he's giving you love ABS killer hi I
want to give a big shout out to starkill
I've been a long time since the creator
has publicly supported me like he has
excuse me who am I
you know what I mean what am I doing
you're getting all the credit yeah I
don't know
are you G7
I don't think so well there you go
field G7 I don't think I'm G7 I'll be G7
for filthy I'm G9
the game is over
and has been for two days
um fousey ended a stream at the airport
we saw that shortly after he's okay so
apparently fousey showed his dick on
stream
but I haven't seen evidence of that
I have not seen that either apparently
he was in the shower
and his friend walked in with the
streaming phone and showed it showed
showed [__] yeah I did see the the
stream come back
but I I did not see
the D if that really happened wouldn't
he have been banned already
maybe it wasn't full dong maybe it was
like
talk little peek I think that's enough
and you end the stream delete what
immediately you can get away with it
really by showing and showing dick yeah
if you're super quick in your mods
remove clips for sure he's not that big
of a streamer he doesn't have that many
of yours yeah how dare you he's number
10 in the world bro out of yours
subscribers though he's way up
yeah you have a weird conspiracy about
his sub count or was it like one person
gave 10 000 of the 18 or something it's
right it's possible he has like a
massive juicer Oiler like that's just
that loves him and gives him a bunch of
money but I did throw out the idea there
that he might be gifting himself no I
don't think so
but yeah he'd probably just have a big
fan that is a multi multi-millionaire or
something Abe saved fousey again with a
text to voice to text oh God do any
context about what so yeah he was there
was this girl I I wasn't really
following at this point this is before I
was G7 you know I was still one foot in
the door G3 yeah I was G3 he uh was
talking to this girl and went back to
our hotel room I didn't know if they
were friends prior or what but uh
I couldn't tell if they were both under
I thought they were both under the
influence but fuzzi said he doesn't
drink and so I was just trying to
protect and make sure he doesn't make
any mistakes so I was texting TTS to him
to try to distract him and I didn't know
what to do so I was just setting him
lines from Back to the Future
so you think that helped it did it
killed a lot of time until Chad
basically convinced him to leave so even
looking at this I'm like oh God I don't
like this
but he's a good man and plus like what's
the chance that someone wearing and I'm
not saying this about fousey butt if you
see a dude wearing a
Bass Pro Shop hat the chances that they
are willing to commit essay pretty high
yeah that's a joke
that was hilarious but I do like to uh
stereotype the Bass Pro hat wears
[__] you never fished in your life stop
it take that off
I have buried the DeLorean in the
abandoned Delgado mine adjacent to the
old Boothill Cemetery as shown on the
enclosed map
hopefully it should remain undisturbed
and preserved until you uncover it in
1955.
inside you will find repair instructions
that's good you got the whole thing off
I'm confused
snapped out of it that's like my third
donation I I did the whole letter that
doc sent Marty when he got sent back to
88 1885. fantastic yeah bro giving side
quests right
that's more than side quest brother
hopefully you don't need that DeLorean
that's what that's what we're trying to
make sure there were just so many
situations inside characters that
occurred during the Stream So this next
one I'm gonna have to walk you through
this you have to pause at certain points
but
it's juicy this is just an example one
of the many situations and this is what
a lot of people wanted to talk about all
right here's fousey getting into
cheating problems oh
McFly
another one
oh okay Foose oh did that help damn
so yeah he just okay he kisses a girl
whatever and then uh shortly after he
shouts me out for giving him love you
could you could proceed that part's
important it is it's important it's
important because
as soon as I like someone or something
happens and they get canceled yeah I've
let it is there any other times he
shouted you out that we maybe we get a
whole compilation of it oh there is but
I didn't include him he he said some
really nice stuff about me
yeah
really we should pull some of those Zach
psych wait what do you say just kidding
are you talking about my by my boxing
match and uh
oh he didn't know I mean I heard one he
said really nice about your boxing match
they respect you getting in the ring and
all that that's awesome yeah
burrito or Taiwanese Taiwanese
food there is a spot that is fire wait
what is it like noodles dumplings
do they have like a stir-fry chicken
situation with like vegetables because
that's what I'm into okay yeah mostly
I'd like to get in spicy
spicy chicken stir-fry with veggies I
can send the menu as well that's [__]
golf
oh
what the pants all right yo a B I don't
know why you're being so kind to me I'm
not used to other creators being this
kind
I just heard my name and then
immediately he's getting a bunch of [__]
from chat saying that he cheated and I'm
like I didn't even I he says he doesn't
have a girlfriend
but uh immediately he started to get a
bunch of [__] saying that his girlfriend
who he said he said it's not his
girlfriend let me be clear but she's at
home watching his dog uh she's on stream
right now like pissed off okay can I
defend him a little bit she kissed him
like if you go back I don't think he
reciprocated let's analyze okay
right like I mean he could have pulled
away I guess a lot of people were
defending him at this point but that but
it's just getting started oh does he
Circle back to her you gotta watch okay
so that's a problem that's a problem
confused not you other creators being
this kind
yeah of course those are important
so this is the girl who's watching
that's his dog right now so this is his
quote not girlfriend yes or in the words
of Mitch Hedberg I don't have a
girlfriend just a girl that'd be really
mad if she heard me say that
and so she's live at the same time
oh [__] so crash cut to his not
girlfriend who's watching his stream
fantastic this is
so everyone's saying it's my fault okay
now we're back to Goosey yes now back to
fousey this is a girl he kissed no the
other girl this is the Garlic yeah this
rocks oh
and again this is a whole storyline on
its own because he met these girls in
the beginning of the night had a crazy
night and then ran into them several
hours later there's a lot of recurring
characters in this world wow that's
amazing I need to start watching we need
to put this on TV look we need to
Syndicate this can I TiVo it next time
I got you thank you causes whatever
you guys can get as mad at me as you
want y'all cause this
I asked y'all respectfully do not go do
anything do not say anything but y'all
are so goddamn nosy and in everybody's
[__] business that before even giving
me a chance to get to La and have the
conversation I intended the new business
100 y'all ain't nobody asked you
[__] what is he saying I'm
confused that uh they they instigated
by telling her immediately while she's
on stream [__]
bro
obviously come on now
okay now this is important this is this
is me I had her stream up and his stream
up at the same time you're streaming
yourself watching yeah and I was
watching her stream and his stream at
the same time okay so you were given
that overhead coverage exactly play by
play immediately after this the VOD is
deleted
so that oh so that his girl doesn't or
the girl's not his girl doesn't see this
footage and she sees it through my VOD
oh so wait is he mad at you then no no
the next day look at these two the next
day he was uh he was showing his friend
he was showing his friend the clip and
laughing about it so I guess he was cool
with it
I didn't mean to I was just
well here it is his ear Mike is on his
ear what did she say she said turn the
camera away so yeah in that moment she
said turn the camera away the other girl
said turn the camera away but his
microphone was on his hat
it was tucked into his hat and so when
she said that the mic got it so clear
that she said turn the camera away
awesome the camera turns and then you
could hear them like
making out aggressively
nobody would have heard that's awesome
hold on let me go back let me go back
is the girl in the corner rushing over
there to bust him I was making that joke
I had a mute where the kissing noises
was because there was a music playing
and the other girls now now did she
react to this that not his girlfriend
yeah and that's coming up I'm assuming
uh no I can't find that exact moment
what was the reaction uh it was uh not
happy and people were telling her to to
message me and I was like please don't
just leave oh God you're getting in the
middle of this [__] bro
did she message you
I did not check you better check right
now
how would she message you on Twitch uh
yeah I think so let me see wait this
food looks insane beat this beef roll
looks nuts
um this chicken dish looks really good
too but I want more vegetables in it
and I don't see the option to add I can
I can do it Ethan you can get veggies in
there yeah like broccoli or whatever
would be great I'm talking about the
three cup chicken that's what I that's
what I got for you that's a good one
vegetables also can you get me the um
the beef roll that just looks phenomenal
yeah
love that uh she did message me okay
read it right now wait she said babies
inserted himself into the middle of this
I feel like I'm in a divorce right now I
don't want to choose you did this bro
this is the destiny you chose for
yourself [__] yeah she said uh hi
just hi just hi
I'm confused is she actually his
girlfriend or no
she even emerged that they
they've only been like uh they're on a
break they were they were on the time
for like 14 days she's with his dog so
they're not exclusive yeah let's put it
this way yeah she's dog sitting fousey
explains a little bit more in the next
uh
just crazy that it's on stream I guess
for her to see with his dog
Lucy is live with the same girl right
now oh [__] let's oh he's coming back to
LA yeah
oh yeah he's coming back today and he's
coming on Wednesday don't get arrested
before then please bro man it is
Wednesday shots are
he is flying has he made it off the
plane safely yet
oh let's see what foosie's up to real
fast he's on his way to the airport
again okay you know what I'm not
watching this [__] ad let's watch
this video
oh yeah he's flying right now my dumbass
my dumbass yo she Whispers in my ear she
says show me don't show me she Whispers
in my ear and says
you didn't hear it but in the background
oh that's you it's my clip
she said turn the camera away dog okay
well now you're [__] it up
oh I literally don't cheat I dare any of
y'all to try to say last night was
cheating huh I dare any of y'all would
say last night that's a [__] I think
I'm cheating cheating is when you're in
a committed relationship okay you step
outside of those boundaries and commit
treason treason
[Laughter]
when you commit espionage
he's like
did you tell her you want to be in a
committed relationship with her
I told her I could see myself in a
committed room oh brother yeah I didn't
say we're Anna committed I said we could
see each other she's she's with your dog
bro she's she's house sitting with your
dog
all right
okay
dogs uh okay so that's that's that I
guess or no we have more new Side
characters Ross the Boss yeah that's
another thing he just kept meeting these
people that were just reoccurring
characters and this guy was amazing this
guy goes by Ross the Boss wait what the
[__] is this this isn't live it's like
night time
this is just playing his Clips while
he's away
um huh he's on that [__] man he's on
that Grind All right so we have more
Side characters Ross the Boss Akeem star
variant interesting oh yeah
how many um
how many what's his K what's his kill
death ratio
his game starts like at two I think
Daddy
I'm not sure but he acts like he has a
high KD he's Ross the Boss it also looks
like he's wearing a g fuel huh yeah so
fousey just met this guy out of nowhere
and then just like he's like come with
me fousey and took him all around
Houston and this guy had the hookup
everywhere at one point takes him to a
cookie shop that has like a secret Club
in the back it was just unreal
see and I need it now it's my [__] he
looks like Mac Miller Plus keemstar
Mac Miller it's in the face it's fake he
has a Mac Miller's face like identical
nobody identical it is look at that you
got you back let's see what you're
saying maybe when he's like in motion
hmm
okay whatever
and the whole time he keeps saying don't
tell my wife that's Ross's line don't
tell my wife take my wife please
[Music]
wait this man is wearing a shirt that
says it's my [__]
on my face
oh and I need it now oh that's or the
line is from it's my [__] and hiding it
now on a shirt
that's hot that's that
I want a road trip cross country with
them
pass
then he started like playing security
for fousey
all right
I'm not the one
you know
who I am he said that oh my god dude
yeah you know who I am yo I want that
[__] and I want it now son
you know who I am
Uber call The Uber
okay holy [__] holy [__] bro I need to
go
oh my God
okay my goodness my goodness I just want
you to see Ross's stance it's coming up
we're good right here
it's giving kemosabe he looks like a
little Bert Chrysler
this guy's awesome
I want that [__] and I want it right
now
and [__] too
uh Texas he got from Ross the Boss uh
fousey took a shower and a sink let me
watch that that sounds pretty good
these pictures are cracking me up
it's the best [__] content ever dude
that's everything to me right now
a little bit more hate them you will be
entertained
get the armpits
at the Dome
there it is fousey's having a good time
out there
getting into a little trouble
we'll see him on Wednesday
all right let's talk about Colleen
Colleen Ballinger let's get to Ethan's
opinion up because apparently the
lawyers are watching now
this is all in my opinion
obviously
you know what I mean
this hat is so big on me
all right [__] me right
there's been a lot of stuff coming out
drip drip drip
this one
I think all disturbed us fairly well
I had seen this before like when I was
consuming their content and I remember
thinking like oh that's a little bit
crazy but I didn't dissect it in the
proper way until this past weekend and I
cannot believe
that they
let alone put it up for children who
watch their content but let alone put it
up for anybody to see like that is so
embarrassing and weird so how old were
you when you watched this 14. oh wow
yeah she's she's really freaky yeah uh
let's check it out
this was Josh's video
is it saying that
refresh
what the f why is he doing that
showing it but it's showing
oh there's no audio to it what the hell
[Music]
I'm clicking the clip to see nothing
going on yeah can somebody send me this
but
it works I click this it's just bugged
out yeah
um thanks Mr Beast
should I hit that
why
nothing happened nothing happened yeah
it's just was glitching out right I
don't think it's even not safe for work
but can you send me
the actual video that works
um
without the NSF thing NSFW
in the meantime Josh made a pretty funny
tweet on uh reaction to Colleen's song
that we watched about the blue eyes you
know
uh golly he says this is actually
stunning breaking my Twitter silence to
clear the air about one specific thing
for what it's worth my eyes are hazel
they've always been Hazel
different colored shirt brings out
different shades but they are hazel
please note this fact if you choose to
write a song about them
that awkward encounter where she was
like uh Josh with blue eyes
they do nothing about blue eyes yep
she's saying Joshua's blue eyes the [__]
he doesn't have blue eyes wait that was
like the one thing that she said about
him he has hazel eyes he says
what can you send me that link again I I
have to watch that back knowing he has
brown eyes
that's crazy
what
uh you guys find that clip I I yeah I
ripped it and
uh oops
there you go
here it is thank you
guys so we're home stop her hand is down
my fans right now
what no no it's not it's okay I'm her
husband what are you doing
I feel weird yeah I mean you guys could
have just edited this out right it's
been good stop oh well also they
clickbaited the title of it was my wife
put her pants down my pants
yeah that was the time it was okay so
this is the end of their honeymoon so
they vlogged every single day they went
to Mexico they went to Hawaii they're
finally home this is the last scene of
like their their vlogged honeymoon
and
it gets a little crazy okay hey so I
just want seriously baby this is the
Vlog I'm not editing this out because I
am not a good idea I won't I love you
I'm just trying to close the honeymoon
vlogs
yank don't Yank on that
thank you for watching the honeymoon
Vlogs thank you for being patient when
they
[Music]
when they were a little bit late and
sometimes he got more than one in a day
we're going back to normal starting
today
I love you guys thanks for for watching
and being impatient we had an amazing
honeymoon and an amazing wedding and we
love each other so much
[Music]
I'll see you guys tomorrow
wait what was that what's the blowing
thing that was his sign out he used to
always say like be nice to people or of
law
what the [__] what that's what is that
he blows out a peace sign I don't know
he's blowing out a peace sign yeah
thought he was blowing his load into his
pants
I wouldn't be surprised so again this is
this is actually pretty pretty [__]
weird and bad
again you were 14 when you watched this
right
[Music]
just I don't know her her brain is just
not normal in the sense that as a person
who's entertaining kids you gotta
understand
at least a little bit about what's
appropriate and not
for them to see it's pretty weird right
well this was his channel so he edited
it and put it up yeah she knew about it
yeah she knew about it
I mean people are only watching it for
her nobody cares about Josh and his
[__] hazel eyes not even Colleen
here it is
I mean his
I'm looking at him here the same view
she has
[Music]
they don't look blue here either man
those look brown eyes
right I mean those are just brown eyes
he said Hazel okay I you know what if
Hazel is [__] you have brown eyes
people they want to be special [__]
I'm sorry my mom my whole life she goes
oh you have beautiful hazel eyes no oh
well that's just your mom bullshitting
you you have brown eyes but people have
hazel eyes I have Hazel I have hazel
eyes come here let me see him
Hazel is a conspiracy for brown eyes
conspiracy it's a real thing
okay you have brown eyes you have brown
eyes bro I'm sorry to tell you dude you
just have [__] brown eyed
Normie sure
you got you need light look they're
light but it's still a brown this is
what hazel eyes looks like that's like
green like well that's what a Hazel is
it's a mixture of green Olivia's is
green brown okay then come here Olivia
do that to my eye me well you just you
just confirmed he has hazel eyes yeah I
did okay come here then look do it to my
eye
foreign
you're a hunk bro
taking a close-up picture that being
said you have brown eyes I mean listen
they're not like Dan's beautiful Blues
but
wait this is I don't have blue eyes I
have um I have gray Silver Eyes actually
I was trying to I'm just trying I was
trying to bait Ethan into yellow you
have blue eyes you did it you know what
I mean yeah they're actually striking
you did it you got those beautiful Blues
Hazel's just [__] I'm sorry if you
look at anyone with brown eyes and you
put a light in their eye it will look
Hazel you know I have one eye is like a
light brown in one eyes like a dark
brown on my face no that's something
true about me okay
you guys are special your Hazel well
guess what
a light Hazel and the other one is like
dark Hazel yeah yeah
um
yeah it's just maybe it's just my mom
[__] me up because it always annoys me
she goes you have beautiful hazel eyes
it's like Mom I have brown eyes stop you
have light brown eyes though they're
brown eyes what are we doing here you
know
baby you did not just I gotta prove my
point that's insane let's see it I sent
it
oh wow okay yeah Hazel dude because
there's a light right in it like I'll do
that too wow here I'll do that too yep
and I got brown eyes nobody's going
Ethan is hazel eyes there goes Ethan is
beautiful hazel eyes
nobody says that no one's ever said that
nobody except my mom your mother has
yeah
[Music]
here someone needs to come shut can you
see the flash you need the flesh
need a flash can I
[Music]
here you do it with the flash on yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
beautiful hazel eyes
oh yeah look at those Hazel puppies
now those are some beautiful Hazels
wow here with the class let's see I'm
going to cam I want to see you guys got
me checking my brown eyes to see if
they're Hazel are they Hazel or no
they're brown they're brown thank you
now let me look at your eyes and see if
I can say they're Hazel
[Music]
is very nice
beautiful eyes cam very nice
how did you guys even
oh do you want me to take for you sure I
guess I mean we know yours and I'm just
curious what it if it actually makes a
difference with the flash like it does
Olivia come you got to do mine closer
because look how close babies is like
it's obscene
how'd you do that baby
my shaky ass hands it wasn't easy
[Music]
I just aimed it towards my face
myself
so everybody is we are evaluating our
beautiful greens
beautiful stunning green eyes
no I'm good I'm good look you guys are
gonna freak out when you see how green
and Hazel my beautiful eyes are
absolutely stunning are you sending it
I'm gonna send it in what's up right now
[Music]
look at those you know beautiful
hold up Dan those look pretty brown to
me wait let me let me enhance my God
the brownest guys I've ever seen in my
life okay then come back and do another
one because okay you've never seen a
Browner either side by side and it'll be
more green this time yeah one second
stop Dan
I'm dead serious you've never seen an
eye more Brown what does that mean in
your whole life
that is like er brown right there dude
that is like a Hazel no Hazel not here's
Hazel oh here's a B's
look at those
you see this brown Hazel Brown look at
the borders if you look at the borders
there's even like a shield stock to mine
Dan there's like a hint of of uh of blue
even oh wow beautiful yeah thank you
okay I don't know what's going on but
his light is brighter baby how about you
try taking it for him my hands are too
shaking yeah he's too biased you want me
to try it with baby's light you think
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah can you
bring your light
you're a frog
I mean look at this
[Music]
okay so wait and then let me put on the
light on mine here too
okay so which one are you gonna
people are saying they look like
hamburgers that's what's up
okay does that look good like with the
light in it yeah we're giving ourselves
literally like the best possible
okay a little bit green maybe you turn
this way so the golden reflects
encouraging this Behavior chocolate
mocha you know colored cream yeah
they're all different flavors
all right
I'm just imagine Colleen's lawyers I
can't open it
trying so hard to open my damn eye
baby get out of here what are you doing
get out of here
send it
was bright on the first one I'm gonna
send it I'm gonna send it
it's not working that's my eye no I'm
kidding I think that's Hazel isn't it
here let me see which one is the best
one
[Music]
you're not getting close enough girl my
hands are shaky that's right yeah here
let me just
and let's get really close
Colleen's lawyers are getting paid good
money to watch this right now
just in the middle
all right well they're doing that let me
just read some stupid jokes or something
so keep things fun fact blue eyes aren't
actually blue what does that mean mark
oh yeah yours are better what does that
mean
but I think what color are they I think
yours are more Hazel than mine I just
gotta say it
well listen I'm not out here saying I
got hazel eyes right you're not totally
you'd be right to say that you don't
because there's a brown well pull it up
show him uh
here what are you talking about what are
you talking about Dan
that's what I saw when I took it
oh
Emerald wow yeah beautiful that's rare
that's okay that's extremely rare yeah
all right I mean here that's good luck
display
very hazel-ish
very very very the brownest thing I've
ever looked at in my life my eye looks
so nasty up close like my my tear duct
looks like open flesh wound
yeah pretty much
nasty
look at that tight little pupil
that looks so nice look at a tight
little Iris dude I'm getting out of here
man get me out of this
laughs
all right where the [__] were we oh yeah
so this so actually he's kind of lying
though if you look at Josh's eye color
yeah it's definitely he he posted a
tweet that was like I was kind of
trolling but yes it is Hazel on his
license
like you could say that they're blue
that's what he's saying look at his eyes
bro why are you lying what they're
really lying dude he you're literally
lying dude no he posted a tweet that
says it ain't that serious y'all I'm
just poking fun about something awkward
that probably happened years ago instead
of making jokes you basically might as
well pull a ukulele at this point
because you got also accused of grooming
brother yeah he should pull out the
guitar
you know let's not be talking about your
eye color let's be talking about the
accusations bro right right because he
did he came out of hiding to make this
joke about the eyes yeah which is like
did you have to
let's look at this job
okay so blue would be in this bracket
I mean he is kind of in the blue bracket
back here
green Hazel that's where I am wait the
green Hazel to blue haze Amber wait wait
wait Hazel yes or Amber yeah you are
Amber yo I have Amber eyes
Amber so it's so perfect Amber is the
color of my energy
whoa
I'm realizing that I have hazel eyes
guys look at that chart of course you
have beautiful hazel eyes like everybody
no you have Blues no look it says green
Hazel to Blue Hazel blue Hazel is a
thing you have beautiful Blues I'm gonna
make you a song Here look
look it's got like the Green in there no
you're you're I think I have hazel eyes
I didn't know blue Hazel was a thing but
I think you're right well I think I have
hazel eyes okay we all have everybody
has hazel eyes no you have brown eyes no
I have Amber eyes
yeah Hazel Brothers Hazel Brothers could
practically be related oh okay but
basically Josh is a liar
guys yeah yeah he's a Weasley little
liar dude why would you if you lie about
that what wouldn't he lie about yeah
what else are you lying about God hates
Liars also we've got that Kobe person we
avatar haircut
he does that's exciting you have nice
hair do something else pretty sure
that's from his divorce announcement
video no wonder she left you bro
just kidding because of those stupid
dumbass hazel eyes
who else is Hazel in here it's pretty
it's like all of us but Ethan right I
just have brown eyes
are the only one oh in love of course
see I think I'm blue Hazel I'm realizing
we all have Hazel too we all have them I
sent it in Discord we all we also have
blue blue eyes here I got Sam's uh hazel
eyes apparently
doesn't look as gnarly as mine dude
wow that is a very beautiful eye wow I
got a load of that I can write a poem
about that Eye
samanthus blue hazel eyes
look at this man
that's [__] videos
[Music]
sometimes they're green he's like yup
usually I'm loving only his reaction
here go from the hand job to this wow A
lot has changed wow what happened a lot
has changed dude he look at I mean
it's like my license
[Music]
up
he hates her yeah yeah me too yeah so
anyway they're relatable and there's
that uh
there was that [__] video which
just another really weird thing in her
history of really weird stuff
whose eyes
I can have whatever I want I have a news
yeah I have a news this is my eye now
that's sick of Photoshop that'd be cool
if people had purple eyes if we had like
a little bit wide of a range didn't
Elizabeth Taylor have purple eyes yeah I
was gonna say Elizabeth Taylor yeah what
they were so beautiful show me a picture
she didn't have purple and cracked she
for sure she for sure had hazel eyes she
for sure had hazel eyes
oh yes fusi on his way to streaming the
studio and docs and the crew I said if
you come please I ask one thing please
please please just do not dox us
he said I got you well Elizabeth Taylor
had blue eyes
afraid to break a teal they appear
purple in some photos due to lighting
makeup and clothing oh boo I heard she
had Hazels they are very pretty though I
heard she got purples
well like I see the photo that you're
talking about and they they look very
purple but it's clearly not true love
has hazel eyes too
dude look at these brown right here
those are Haze that's Hazel I'm hazed
out Hazel gang also a very smaller
[__] little eye hole
I had I have a fat loose sloppy eyeball
tell me about it worn out worn out so
many tears over the years oh true that's
well said yeah
yeah let me pull up my [__] eye hole
again
look how big it is
something ain't right with that why does
it look so gashed
what the hell that's Ashkenazi eye right
true
that's a rat hole
all right so there's that I mean that's
that's what you get I want to talk about
the um James Charles stuff now I've been
dying to talk about this oh and then the
Boogie has a 20 year old girlfriend we
get to talk about there's so many good
things oh Cafe's YouTube channel I'm
just I'm buzzing oh he's buzzing with an
excitement here people all right let's
get the James Charles one out of the way
just so we hit everything in the title
and then we can go off the rails okay
what mascara does Sam use
ayek she's not sitting here but I
actually know the answer to this is it
the yeah
[Music]
she knows she knows L'Oreal telescopic
lift let's go is that the one she was
she was selling yeah no I literally I
bought it because of that controversy
and it's actually the best mascara in
the world no wonder she didn't remove it
it's really good by her word L'Oreal was
like do not re move that video all press
is good for us
makeup bags makeup bag
like baby baby baby
[Laughter]
she just got married I know I saw good
for her all right let's talk about James
so
Cosmopolitan I guess I guess these these
printed magazines are down bad because
why the [__] would they run this story
now here here okay
this is like a feature-ass store oh yeah
yeah
would like to be uncanceled please now
what happened here did they reach out
was this James PR public is reaching out
was there an exchange of money like what
do we think happened
I'm not sure I I am very curious though
I wouldn't say like a direct exchange of
money but yes he's launching a new uh
product line right right here right this
is the main page yeah oh I think they
paid then he he probably paid them
because he's this is all about him
launching this new makeup line yeah
there would have to be some sort of
disclosure if that were the case which
I'd not see I don't think so
um Cosmopolitan they're a mainstream
enough dude no some like Fly by Night
website you know what I mean no I don't
think you have to disclose if you were
paid to write an article that was like a
huge issue it was called like um
integrated like sponsors or something
it's like a big issue right in the
marketing world I don't think they have
to disclose that
unless it's changed since a couple years
ago
um
but I just don't know why they would put
their neck out for him
yeah that's a good question because like
he is Undisputed a total freak psycho
Predator just a really just shitty guy
who should nobody should be associating
with
and to this day there's still a lot of
celebrities that collab with him and I I
hate to say it but even my good friend a
friend of the show
uh some friends of the show I want name
names although I should I just can't
recall it right now
so um let's see I would like for you all
to forget about me being a predator
please
more than two years after allegations of
sexual impropriety sent to Superstar
Beauty YouTuber influencer and purgatory
Purgatory he should be in jail
he's hoping to relaunch himself and his
brand with the help of a new makeup line
guys I'm trying to make money
I want to show you how authentic I am by
I just really want to make money from
this makeup I would date like the
absolute youngest everybody in the chat
who's saying it says in the article that
he hired a PR team that that's not
that's not what's in question yeah of
course he has a PR team and yeah of
course they likely yeah so they they
push for this article yeah they have a
relationship with them I'm more
wondering if it's paid to play or not
which is a different question if they I
think I still think that they would have
to disclose that but Ethan's more
skeptical that's what I'm reading yeah
any paid press needs to be disclosed
I've even done like SEO jobs before and
I know that you have to disclose if it's
like an ad
or a paid for article
yeah I think it could be something more
subtle where it's like the pr has a deep
connection with them that yeah a
thousand percent because yeah that's how
the whole industry works but it has to
be a little bit more subtle than that
than just we'll pay you
twenty thousand dollars to publish an
article about our client and this
article is certainly not unbiased so
there was definitely
she was writing in his favor there was
supervised yes
yeah I mean it is getting them a lot of
views I'm assuming but
at what cost not a good look so let's
look at the synopsis here
in the title line more than two years
after I read that yada yada he says in a
wide-ranging interview with
cosmotopolitan Charles talks about
[__] up and trying to move on
from chat can't wait to see his makeup
line on TJ Maxx
for sure
maybe TJ Maxx can make like a mashup of
of canceled uh
YouTubers a kit James Charles oh some
sort of Jeffree Star Shane Dawson get
them all happening some sort of
clearance collab
um
comes with a a complimentary bottle of
Diamond Water
foreign
James 24 details what happened
he's canceled for inappropriate behavior
I had to do a lot of thinking like okay
babe this is your fault no you're not a
pedophile no you're not a [__]
groomer no you're not a predator but you
made a big mistake so what was the
mistake what was the big mistake well
probably the grooming in the predatory
stuff that he didn't do Insane choice of
words for this sentence like okay babe
this is not your fault you are not a
pedophile
we didn't want to be like oh wait can I
actually take away the word babe
if I'm gonna be so serious about this
listen babe you don't like babies
right
so did they even challenge this I mean
here's that line let us begin I don't
want to sit here and [__] mope and
whine and cry because nobody wants to
hear it it says Charles
sinking into a plush couch in his casual
open living room oh yeah sounds like
he's living Purgatory It's hard out
there man pause
by the way he's not canceled
he's not
there's talk about that in this article
actually he's just not canceled a lot of
people are mad at him but he still has a
career do not want to get canceled
yeah no the author actually does kind of
meditate on what that really means if he
still has lots of fans and is making
money and stuff so
it's still a [__] article but
they acknowledge that sort of
self-contradict and contradiction that's
going on one line where I was like oh
okay maybe maybe we were trying to get
somewhere but we didn't get there
I want to see if they challenge him on
this
so he says okay babe you're not a
groomer you're not a [__] Predator
you're not a pedophile you just made a
huge huge huge potential or actually a
legal mistake that could put me in
prison
at this point you're likely familiar
with the status quid quo pro inherent
and celebrity profiles
the ones that have come together post
cancellation after a respectable amount
of time has passed host cancelable sin
it's not surprised that a star's
willingness to answer intimate questions
about a catastrophic stretch of their
lives increased dramatically when they
have a project to promote
in today's case this ostensibly Charles
new makeup line painted but it's also
Charles himself
so they did not they did not challenge
this I'm not a predator
kind of just skimmed by that yeah
uh Cosmopolitan claims to have reached
out to a few of the miners who had
accused James of inappropriate behavior
uh here's this excerpt they got
uh one asked if we would be willing to
pay
it's like they tried their best why
would they discredit did they need to
include that I don't think so
because that clearly
it's clearly there to do something right
one has to be willing to pay and did not
reply again when we told uh
told them that we do not compensate our
sources
I mean yeah pay I think you should
[__] they're like I've been through
enough [__] if you want me to be part of
his uh Redemption Arc pay me [__] yeah
they already told their story and pretty
much no one listened to them anyway why
would they do it again I feel like the
kid the dude I fully backed them up like
how many times in my career have people
just stole my content re-upload it
nobody wants to pay for [__] [__] you
cosmopolitan
uh but from another former accuser wrote
back via Instagram dm with a new
revelation he had he said already
privately apologized to Charles a few
months ago for telling him I was 18 a
few years ago and The Tick Tock I made
that blew up the situation wow wow what
are the odds that the only two ended up
like that
when we asked to elaborate the person
did not reply uh Charles team says
someone did message Charles this spring
admitting he lied about his age
dude this is pathetic there are a lot of
credible allegations
well all but again like
we've discussed this
at length but it doesn't even really
matter that they lied about their age
does it
um
like you're a celebrity talking to a 16
year old
maybe even younger
um there was one fort alleged 14 year
old
that's skinny that's actually pedo
territory
he James says that he lied about his age
um 14 that's petal territory
14. it's 14. it's just like if it's
caused so much of a problem in your
career if if this is not real and you
really are not a predator and like it
just so happens that this has been
happening in your career
get off of every single dating app it's
so clear that like this is a problem
because he refuses to to even stop in
the first place and makes it pretty
public that he doesn't stop
like you're on all these apps this is
nauseating like this this quote here is
just so pathetic of them
why are you whitewashing him anybody
else if this was a a dude and a woman
if this was a straight guy
and his victims were women this article
would not be being written period right
yeah
I don't think so
but we can just gloss over it when it's
James Charles and he's like
preying on men
desperation
yeah why don't you include this
cosmopolitan
sent include this picture I would
literally take you 30 seconds to send a
pic like this that's crazy like he's
that is crazy and I don't remember if
this was to a minor or what
this is to the 16 year old this was to a
16 year old Cosmopolitan it would
literally take you 30 seconds to send a
pic like this
James why do you want you expect all
your men to have vibrant armpit hair yet
you wax yours explain
this whole picture in my opinion kind of
implies that they said No at first and
he's like oh let's just take you 30
seconds to do this like again like using
his power kind of pushing even if they
weren't underage it would be insanely
inappropriate to do that the entire yeah
this entire thing is it says it all
perfectly this is just straight up
coercion exactly yeah
show us child pornography
here at Cosmopolitan can you include all
these please you [__] losers I'm just
laying here bored and horny ha ha ha ha
ha
16 year old allegedly this was sent to
did you see this one cosmopolitan
what about this one
do you have a nice body
[Applause]
jump scares [__] dude
hey Cosmopolitan did you see this one
oh come pick me up for some road head
bro what's up what
is going on
no he's he's he's awesome man and this
is he's made huge mistakes right
devastating mistakes huge mistake he's
not a predator though or a groomer
of course not
[__]
did this whoever wrote this should be
ashamed and the editor too my God older
guys like why are we laundering the
reputations of predators why are we
doing this so we can sell some makeup
Blown Away
stunning
let's see does that make sister sense
uh James reveals in this article that
the accusations from 21
are the reason he and his younger
brother haven't spoken two years now
that is pretty damning his own brother
who you stood Duke his content with him
like he used to be in videos with James
that's pretty serious your own brother
says I'm not even going to deal with you
anymore yeah that's a that's a pretty
big condemnation if you remember when
this all first began coming out Jeffree
Star
unknowingly tweeted like bashing James's
little brother but James James's little
brother had tweeted out something that
wasn't even about James in the first
place here let me find it I remember
that and that that was when he was like
kicked off of the internet
his bro yeah Jeffree Star just like
attacked him when James was being uh
exposed for no reason good guy all these
hey man if you sell them if you if
you're a man that sells makeup online
actually the chances are if you smell
sell makeup online you suck there's like
weird it's got to be like 80 here we go
so he tweeted out which apparently had
nothing to do with
um James why does everyone act so tough
on the internet and Jeffree Star quote
tweeted it why is your brother a
predator why'd you really move back to
NYC exactly shut the [__] up he was like
16. ah
wow
he's cool man Jeffries cool he's on the
yacht Farm killing [__] animals and
packing them up and doing rituals yeah
yeah no he was 17 when this happened
he's healed
yeah
um James on why he would seek out
relationships via Instagram and other
social media apps now this is the best
part
listen closely
as it's clear he's changed quickly
please name five famous male gay
celebrities from the ages of 20 to 25 he
says you can't because they don't exist
all right
James Charles is the only gay celebrity
between 20 and he's got a point
the only one he's so right away
therefore I need to prey on people on
Instagram yeah
no other Ops and he's he's essentially
saying in my opinion that he's still
doing he's still on messaging people on
Instagram yeah because you would be very
very upfront and very clear if if you
were not engaging in stuff like that
anymore and it had caused so much
trouble but quickly he goes quickly name
five yeah he's been thinking about that
one
can we make a list maybe to help I mean
I don't think I can prepare one if you
would like can you can you ask Chachi BT
to make me a list of
gay male celebrities between the age of
20 and 25. I think chat two people like
what is the purpose of this list
I don't feel comfortable crafting this
list
James answers about why he doesn't seek
out relationships reveal Via Real dating
apps dating apps designed for people
like him like Raya
even confused the author of this puff
piece let's take a look
I still have to ask though why didn't he
just stick to actual adult dating apps
he tells me he previously had accounts
on Raya Tinder hinge and Bumble and
while he did go on dates with people he
met there he ultimately felt too exposed
you [__] [__] that's crazy
you felt too Exposed on a dating app
where you're supposed to all be there
for dating but you don't mind just
damning random people
yeah that's how you got exposed that
doesn't make any sense
what he means is that we're on people
understand my expectations and it's not
fun unless I'm trying to coerce straight
young men to send me armpit hairs
he says like anyone he swiped right on
was going to take screenshots of their
combo or brag about to their friends and
yeah all the people you talk to on
Instagram are doing that too dummy
he doesn't fully address that anyone's
social media platforms could do the same
right hey guess what if you don't write
things worth screenshotting they won't
screenshot it that's pretty simple the
other thing but you know
on dating apps it says your age so maybe
the dating apps didn't allow him to
cater to his Vice that's true
because they're all over 18. it's a fair
assumption okay so chat gbt did give me
a list
I don't know who most of these people
are but it's not really my scene that
the this demographic of men sure
maybe you guys know who they are Lil
NADA little Naz X oh we haven't
collapsed before we have a whole list a
little Nas yeah but Lomas X
no I'm saying he's he's awake yeah he
doesn't yeah he shouldn't Dip
Top dick he gets better he gets his pick
of the dick absolute yeah
Troy Sivan I don't know who that is very
famous Colton Haynes Haynes heinies Ezra
Miller skip them
Kingdom Lonsdale
Charlie Carver Tommy Dorfman Connor
Jessup Jesse Smollett
some of these guys are over
25 I guess because
um chai gbt only goes the liar
uh Aya Naomi King Ben Platt Ali exander
Ali Alexander Ali Alexander now there
now we're talking about a I don't know
who that is yeah you do oh that's the
proud boy not proud boy but I don't even
know what the [__] he is he was the one
that was rolling with uh Kanye and uh
Fuentes and all those people
the chin guy
the chin guy maybe so I'm thinking of
someone else hold on oh I don't know who
this is this is a British singer Dan
Ali Alexander
oh Ollie all right all Alexander Oh I
thought we were talking about ali who
was all okay yeah no he's the Ching guy
why are you call him the chin guy look
at his chin
oh he does have a fat chin he's got like
an inbred chin that's awesome I mean
that's you know what that's the song's
words I'm taking that back no it looks
like the haps for a jaw that's what yeah
I'm taking that back though everyone's
pulled out um I'll make fun of people
I'll pull out I don't make fun of
people's physical appearance anymore
never
[Music]
uh let's see
uh James new routine for sliding into
someone's DMS he actually outlined it he
says he's more cautious now although not
so much that he's given up DM sliding
completely
[Music]
instead he started requiring potential
romantic interest to provide IDs before
he engages
[Music]
[Applause]
he says I'm a club bouncer at this point
which I love that analogy because
there's just so many underage kids
trying to get in yeah
he's like no no no no no no all these
young boys they come to me they come to
me in groves
maybe I let one slip through every now
and then
the McDonald's play place doesn't count
as a club
wow
good one that's a good point
what if the McDonald's serves alcohol
I've heard some do and uh Europe yeah
love said they have beer in his
McDonald's yeah and and yeah whenever he
does these like comeback
videos apologies pieces it always sounds
like a call to action for people to
slide into his DMS to flirt with him
like he reminds the world I'm looking
for a boyfriend I'm looking for a
boyfriend
or I'll slide into yours like every
single time and if you and just have a
good fake ID yep he lets them know how
to do it over people to be in a
relationship with if you can get in the
club with it you can get in yeah you can
get it I thought this was about your
career I thought you were launching a
makeup brand
are we talking about how to get a
boyfriend look how this author is
laundering his reputation it's obscene
when I pulled friends and colleagues
about Charles and the run-up to this
article the general consensus was that
he had done something bad but no one was
clear on exactly what are you [__]
serious y'all are
apparently like journalists and New
Media and we're like hmm uh you know
it's something bad but gosh I can't
remember what it was nobody said that
everybody knows what he did well I gotta
yeah well they're reporters yeah I mean
if you're not in the system you can
understand but that doesn't mean
anything like if I asked my parents what
James Charles did they wouldn't have a
[__] idea that doesn't mean anything
you know but this idea that he did
something bad but we're not sure what
it's like it couldn't have been that bad
right if we don't we can't even remember
what it was when you go below 16 like 15
and stuff like that that then you know
by all means by all means what keemstar
yeah wait what
um
after all
would a still ousted person be allowed
to pose for Red Carpet cameras at the
People's Choice Awards or chat amicably
with Paparazzi while out and about in
Hollywood yeah as you know Hollywood has
a great reputation in terms of banishing
predators known Predators this is the
section I was referring to earlier about
um wait you're talking about the
Hollywood fix this is your evidence that
he's not canceled
right this is almost always people
calling in on themselves yeah this is
just yeah this is just one dude that
wanders around them he's friends with
all of them them right and by the way
this has 3 000 views nobody even gives a
[__] I'm gonna watch this is interesting
James Charles announces the launch of
his new painted makeup brand
with content winners at boa this is
embarrassing
you just happen to be there
how are you
what's up what's up James hello
congrats man on all your success thank
you
this is stunning
see that stage 100 oh yeah of course
this guy stages everything he's known
yeah he literally just
Chris what does Mr Beast think about
this
[Laughter]
let's see
well here's this is our us live right
now he's pretty into it oh God that's
inappropriate Emma Chamberlain talks
about James Charles for sale one dollar
you don't talk about Emma like that we
like Emma
she's I don't she's like unproblematic
Queen right yeah
good for her
I appreciate it so much this is super
cool and you brought out everybody from
all over all over the world
on social media to find the 10 most
talented artists of all the land to
convince for the painted campaign and
here they all are sitting in their
lovely van
how was it how was the experience okay
we gotta name names here yeah what did I
who are you guys
I don't know and why are you in this van
first of all don't get in any white van
with Jake bad idea
I don't really recognize any of them
everything you thought it would be this
is so sweet and nice and humble it's
like a box
say more continue yeah we're so excited
for the brand Peyton thank you congrats
wow this tour looks super official man
you see that you see this sign on it
wait what that's hype
surprises doesn't say free candy free
the other side you just flip it around
yeah
it's been four years in the making yeah
it's about damn time
um I'm just really pumped I'm really
grateful that everybody's been able to
join the products have been getting
really good reviews for the people that
have used it thus far yeah
so I'm just ready to get out is there a
filter on his face like I know his
makeup is his makeup there might be this
filter is supposed to make you look like
baby
I know his makeup's crazy but if you
look closely at his face I feel like
there's something going on here I think
I think you're right a lot of uh these
new like the new Sony cameras all have
like a built-in face filter
there's something unnatural happening
yeah like soft skin
that's right
[Music]
[Applause]
what a natural organic infection that
was oh he's not writing
why did he throw them all into a van and
then not ride with them enjoy yes that
girl's getting this van
bye dummy see you thank you
okay so yeah again 74 likes 3.7 000
views nobody cares
nice try
love that everyone that is so bizarre I
love that that he's just rfying them
where do you think that Van's going
just around the corner
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys thank you that's
humiliating frankly whoever's in that
car should be so humiliated have fun at
the Holiday Inn yeah I put them all up
at the motel six
what is it Motel 6 Motel Six yeah never
stayed at a Motel Six uh I only did it
once so many times yeah twitchcon Lester
that was a [__] nightmare is it bad
or is it fine it was so bad really I
just kept telling I'm so sorry like
I thought we were past this point of Our
Lives it won't happen again but
everything was booked was it just an
availability thing yeah they gave away
our room at the other Hotel so how much
does it cost to stay at the motel six
six bucks no it was crazy for twitchcon
I forget it was like uh 250 a night or
something
is Sam matching James
saw people pointing this out in the chat
and went and looked it does look like
the same thing doesn't it tell me James
nah Sam have you been in that van
yeah she wore it better oh yeah
come on
yeah this is great
so let's see uh uh where was I reading
here
he had an amicable chat with Paparazzi
you idiot The Hollywood Reporter
who he called to meet him there
Hollywood fix what yeah the Hollywood
fix right
um
still would a still banished person have
hundreds of thousands of fans
enthusiastically engaged with his
YouTube beauty tutorials
hundred thousand is a far cry from what
he used to get
but a truly exiled person be 24 years
old and live what okay what a truly
exiled person be 24 years old
got him
and living in a reportedly seven million
dollar Farmhouse that looks like a cross
between the homes featured in the later
seasons of Vanderpump Rules and any
season of all iterations of the
Kardashians what a sentence God yeah he
made money
he made a lot of money
well I think that
I think that the author is making a
point here that's some Salient I
actually I see it a different way this
is this is a pure puff piecery she's
saying he's not canceled at all the
[__] is back and he never left I see
him like that too okay fair enough [__]
is back yeah he's never left girl don't
call it a comeback he's been here for
years I'll be back for real
you know black and white modern exterior
hyper organized Interiors when I arrived
I noticed Oreo
decanted into glass jars
on a pristine marble kitchen island
she's like so taken by him yeah she
loves it yeah Predator would not have
Oreos and jars stunning yeah that seems
very suspicious
[Applause]
I noticed that as well come on I know
what's going on here she's basically
like as I was troubled by his obvious
predatory behavior it evaporated from my
mind as I noticed his beautiful stunning
marble counters and the jar of lollipops
on the counter beautiful decoration
would a predator have a jar of lollipops
no no
could a predator have a house this
beautiful
[Laughter]
blade technique first popularized by
Khloe Kardashian back when Charles was
in high school this whole paragraph is
[__]
listen to this utopic environment
Charles two dogs black and white were
playing nearby children were laughing in
the air I said why are children here but
I quickly moved on
it was truly remarkable there was one
jar marked roofies the other jar marked
the Oreos right side by side beautiful
I only saw what is the gbt is that the
day the day GHB you'll get that ice GHB
I asked James offered me tea I asked is
there Chi change being it
he said no only for my special guests
there's a lot riding on the answers
painted a solo Adventure four years in
the making no wonder he's desperate to
do this
launches in just a few weeks people have
speculated that I have Partners or
investors which I don't know how that
rumor got started
Charles says this line is fully
self-funded every single dollar that has
gone into the brand has been for my
personal savings and checkings account
great wow can't wait for you to lose all
that I have no investors no Partners no
billion dollar backers behind me I
wonder why
I Cry he's like and trust me I tried
yeah right
uh and then basically I asked everybody
nobody what knows why he was canceled
that neither of us knows how it will go
to due to the murky nature of cancel
culture and this crisscrossing tripwires
of implied and Loosely enforced rules
and because of a hungry and fickle
internet that Doles out forgiveness
seemingly at a whim
it's a landscape a hellscape some would
say in which all comebacks are tentative
and where the conversation around an
offense often ends up obscuring the
offense itself
when I pulled friends and colleagues
about James Charles into the run-up of
this day the general consensus that he
did something bad but no one was clear
on exactly what
sexting 16 year olds yeah that's yeah
just to be clear very concise allegedly
very it's very concise answer
allegedly
that's so embarrassing for this author
let's see
telling about his history don't care
in February
2021 at age 21 Charles confronted a
career crisis he couldn't quickly
apologize for he was accused of sending
lewd photographs an inappropriate sexual
messages to a 16 year old fan okay so
you do know what happened
Charles said he was misled into
believing the boy was 18 and so that
makes it okay
and that he blocked him as soon as he
learned the truth
so I don't think sending dick pics to a
six-year-old I think the act of blocking
doesn't actually uh
reduce the crime there
yeah but have you seen the Oreos I have
they're so they are stunning stunning
double stuff God the beautiful marble
countertops just blinded me stunning
I've never been more disgusted in my
life than when I found out that kid was
16 year old mm-hmm
I was mortified absolutely mortified yep
that fan did not return cosmopolitan's
request for comment yeah they've been
through this [__] years ago why the [__]
do they need to talk to your dumb asses
now
the allegation triggered more complaints
against Charles they were primarily
disseminated in the form of tick tocks
filled with screenshots and flirtatious
conversations
Charles allegedly conducted with a
number of male fans a few of the
reporter accusations like the initial
one were serious and claimed the detail
inappropriate online
uh interaction between Charles and
miners other claims including an
incident
in which Charles allegedly called
someone daddy felt muddier
almost all of them eventually rounded up
Daddy and two viral Twitter threads by a
controversial poster who keeps track of
Internet scandals now Under Fire himself
she literally just
she did she just refer to deaf noodles
yeah okay what okay okay
the fact that she's
she's putting his cancellation solely on
death noodles and saying look how
uncredible he is is insane
oh those are all mine yeah
what the fudge
no I'm good thank you like that that's
that's intentionally so misleading
if it wasn't for uh deaf noodles
look at this
oh God that looks amazing oh my goodness
the cucumber is being keyed out shit's
mom dude
there you go shout out to the Chart off
again
China will never take that one
that's right after I tasted this video
no more one pot I will go to war against
China for this
this is a two China House
wow
it's like pickled cucumber
so good
do you think the Taiwanese were spared
uh from coven
not Chinese enough yeah not Chinese in
it
[Laughter]
um
yes they really link to deaf noodles
what is this article the rise and fall
of deaf noodles what the [__] they're
like get a load of this guy if it wasn't
for him none of this would have happened
looks like they were much more thorough
with the critique of of noodles than
with uh Charles the alleged Predator
different type right oh I see
this one doesn't do the her and Def put
out a tweet like clarifying saying that
uh of the nearly 20 allegations only two
of them were false there's knowledge
and he addressed that
it wasn't just him everyone was talking
about it man we're just [__] dorky
ass picture
look how he's he he's just
that's Purgatory dude he's a suffering
Soul he's in the light he's in the
shadow he wants to be in the light but
he's in the shadow
he wants an armpit hair but he doesn't
have armpit hair
it's the yin yang
in the end substantiated or not
again
basically totally dismissing it's
possible multiple media reports that
indicate that at least 15 boys and men
had accused Charles of inappropriate
behavior so you're suggesting that all
15 may have been not substantiated
15.
half of them are fake
15. let's say 75 of them are fake that's
still five
Charles now says about the breadth of
the allegations the source of where the
list came from was not doing any sort of
research no fact checking
some of the screenshots depicted
consensual conversation adults he says
others were completely fake and never
happened
this is why you don't this is why it's
important to not do what def did in that
sense because
they just focus on the fake one
Eddie ignored the dozens of real ones
and look what a more on this journalist
is to just take this bait and run with
it
um Charles has never been legally
charged with engaging inappropriate with
a minor let alone proven to have
knowingly done so dude what is with this
person
nevertheless doing their job
that April Charles uploaded a 14-minute
video happens to be covering up for
James Charles look no not they go
nevertheless like despite being totally
innocent he still uploaded a video
calling hold my holding myself
accountable where he admitted to
inadvertently exchanging messages with
two six-year-old boys he said he had was
led to believe they're 18 and apologized
for this desperate Behavior I [__] up
I'm desperate
and then here's where they discredit the
victims Cosmopolitan reached out to
multiple people who said who uh want to
ask for pay the other one didn't respond
so there you go that's awesome
if a celebrity with tens of millions of
followers came sliding into your DMs
would you respond I probably would yeah
anyone would
most people would
oh my God you guys this is stunning look
at this I need his makeup you guys
he's an artist you know what I mean it's
unleashing he understood unleash the
artist inside Hello Olivia
no what I love that
hi James
I love this but it's very hard to eat
and also do a live show
so I'm gonna check out this chicken that
was so good dude this is saucy
that's really Saucy sure about that
you're not a sauce boy I'm a sauce boy
but this is Sassy sauce there's nothing
sassy about it come on try chop that
down
see
[Music]
Taiwan deserves to be free
all of us
well it is I'm waiting they deserve
their autonomy and if China ever
attempts Taiwan I will go to the front
line and fight for them right yeah
um
oh I absolutely did [__] up he says
but he denies that he ever engaged in
grooming
he's like I was being a real knucklehead
I mean that's exactly what um
Colleen Did the only thing I've ever
groomed is my two Persians they've
collabs I'm not a groomer I'm just a
loser not a groomer and literally James
Charles
[Music]
I'm just lonely okay
I'm not a groomer I'm just James Charles
maybe James was waiting for something
like the Colleen situation he's like
okay now's my chance to come back oh
yeah that's not what I did was bad but
look at what she did all right in my
bony there's still nothing yeah no it's
just very bad still by comparison even
insane
um I feel like that word is very popular
buzzword he's talking about grooming
um
especially in politics and stuff but the
actual meaning of it has been
misconstrued are you an expert
trust me I would know
referring to the first allegations
against me as the conversation lasts one
hour I didn't know this person I never
met this person nothing ever happened
between me and this person so use the
word is so categorically incorrect okay
fine you're just a predator
you like kids I only tried to [__] this
16 year old for one hour
fine how many times after that did did
more of these encounters happen I think
that's the thing that's so appalling is
it's like
the just Defiance and refusal to
learn from any of this you know he's
still on just being like okay maybe as a
public figure it's not a good idea for
me to be interacting with fans and like
a charge sexual way
um once again no the problem is I just
need to be more I just need to be a
little more careful while I do that
that's the conclusion yeah I'm like a
bouncer at a kid's party insane
[__] weirdo
I got veggies on the side what are these
these are a new type of Veggie just
invented the veggie too it's new veggies
new veggie just dropped I literally
don't know what that is
Taiwanese restaurant it's your new
vegetable you get to name it I thought
it was like a green onion stalk or
something but I don't know what it is
it's not bok choy
can I get some ambient sounds please
yeah one sec
the beef roll in the chili sauce I gave
you fire
okay guys I'm gonna have lunch so I need
you guys not to interrupt me
can I read the super chats maybe sure
okay
uh somebody donated two dollars said
change the background to a different
place and eat we were one step ahead of
you Stephanie one step ahead of you
uh jury
said AO first donation it's my 31st
birthday hey yo proof is my channel
Banner you guys are awesome uh Professor
Channel Banner okay hold on let me check
that that's next level nice yeah yeah
they actually have their ideas their
Channel Banner now please remove it all
right hit them 31.
31 [__] you there you go that was a good
one
content idea get the Hollywood fix out
for h3tf coverage to expose the grift I
don't think they would come out for us
even if uh
even if we uh tried to you don't think
dropping them an anonymous tip Hollywood
fish
uh uh Ethan Klein is at Denny's at three
in the morning by himself farting up a
[__] storm
yeah I don't give a [__] who's that
who cares L I bet I get more than 3 000
views
I don't know a lot more but definitely
more than three they showed up for
keemstar at the airport that one time oh
yeah oh they did okay that then come on
okay here's showing up for keemstar
uh that 27 donation from Kira for asking
for a birthday shout out to my loving
fiance fiance Beyonce Robbie happy 27th
and to many more that's very sweet thank
you Kara
27. [__] you here is um
a tweet from
Jack
thank you
damn I feel super bad for this dude
please don't cancel the totally not
creepy multi-millionaire he only
solicited a couple miners 15 actually
allegedly at least they said at least
15.
um
sorry guys about eating I'm done you
good I just had a couple bites and I'm
I'm gonna wrap it up and bring it home
pick out
was really good though it reheats well
it does good I think the boys will like
this too
Olivia can you do me a favor I'm sorry
can you just fridge this stuff for me
thank you so much
here let me help you pack it up
thank you
um
thank you guys
appreciate that
let's see um
Cosmopolitan reached out to multiple
people
going down
oh I absolutely did [__] up he says he
says grooming is [__] I only tried
to [__] the six-year-old for one hour
and then they go on
in the absence of Hard Evidence hordes
of commenters and bystanders gloomed
glommed onto the idea that Charles was
creepy irresponsible at best
possibly predatory at worst
yeah so hard evidence
yeah what is what is wrong with this
person
I mean
again
he admitted to at least a few of these
he literally admitted to we're not
talking about a hypothetical 16 year old
he confirmed that it happened
what the [__] is this this is this is a
shame in the absence of Hard Evidence
Boards of commenters and bystanders
that's you Ethan glommed on to the idea
that James was creepy
irresponsible potentially predatory at
worst his apology
one in a bird
burgeoning and much mocked genre of
YouTube influencer Maya copas
was full-throated
no pun intended
but it did nothing to quell the fuhrer
fur
after this year the fur
furry the fury he's a fury he's a furry
the fur
Brett Favre
fur
after years of benefiting from online
controversies Charles had officially
become too toxic for the internet
how come it doesn't mention he deleted
his apology too
right he did
I'd like to know why he did that that
would be a good question
if YouTube if his YouTube page was
demonetized he did not return as the
host of instant influencer
okay sorry his YouTube page was
demonetized he did not return to instant
influencer and his other business
ventures languished he had morph and
influencer focus Beauty brand with which
she'd partnered cut ties
uh James's team says this was done at
their own request yeah right shut up
after they saw morph getting backlash
shut up
uh James told me he pocketed a small
amount from the deal that allowed him to
buy his house he bought it in a small
amount to buy a seven million dollar
house and pay off his parents mortgage
the [__] what is all about
James told me he pocketed a small amount
from the deal that allowed him to buy
his house and pay off his parents
mortgage it's just pocket change you
know what I mean it's just like
what's rattling around at the bottom of
the cup holder in your car you just kind
of scoop that up paid off two mortgages
look at this master of craft and his
element
wow truly inspiring damn
uh I can't even begin to explain to you
how bad that week of my life was I feel
so bad
Charles remembers as he looks out in his
back his backyard his expansive yard oh
God my life's so hard as the dogs played
in this beautiful perfect manicured
grass
I was crying myself to sleep every
single night
in between asking for armpit pictures
I was sitting there staring at my phone
waiting for new armpit pictures to come
in
I wanted to kill myself
I wasn't talking to anybody
except the armpit kids
people threw food into his yard
and spray painted his property fence
prompting him to hire security
people threw food into his yard what
like what does that mean
oddly specific
that's awesome like what someone threw
like tomatoes were they throwing
Tomatoes bread
stop with the tomatoes I found a little
bit of
found a little bit of a of a banana peel
and I hired security there were like a
bunch of lemons in my yard people are
throwing it was an attempt on my life
there were lemon peels don't people have
a lemon tree in your backyard they were
unrelated no no different part of the
yard yeah
you know it wasn't that bad because it's
so unspecific and when I woke up in the
morning there was water all over my
grass
they were spray painting my fence it had
all this information about where the gas
lines are in the street stunning the
city came in yeah the city is against me
I think I've always been somebody who's
able it's just that it's just doordash
[Laughter]
they kept coming every day
and bringing me food
it's horrible
I think I've always been somebody who's
been able to cope he continued I've been
able to turn my phone off go to see my
family to have friends over the Escape
rooms wait what
again any room with James Charles is an
escape room James Charles has been
talking about an escape room since like
2015.
to talk about Escape room he just really
likes Escape rooms oh my God you know
I've done you're not done it twice yeah
when he gets his friends in there the
lights go off and he goes I'm not
trapped in here with you you're trapped
in here with me I want to play a game
show me your armpit here
[Laughter]
show me an armpit or I'll kill your
family make your choice make your choice
let me sniff your arm pet Dawn
or I'll kill your dog
uh let's see so he's able to play Mario
Kart play Minecraft build a Lego set we
love that don't play Minecraft it's not
a good look for you oh he's a Lego fan
huh dude this place sounds
yeah this Purgatory sounds like hell
dude they got Mario Kart Legos and Oreos
I would love to go to this place
Minecraft Legos movies Escape rooms it
sounds like hell you know the Lego says
it's for everyone it's not for James not
for you it sounds like a place for kids
no no suit for you welcome everybody
Legos for everybody not you welcome is
for everybody for his Prospect not not
James sure
yeah literally with this situation it's
like a modern day uh Neverland Ranch
yeah
the parallels are there
I just want it to be a fun and magical
environment for children of all ages
come on me ow
what is my okay I won't make the Michael
Jackson jokes it's inappropriate
and it gets too sensitive right ABIA I
kind of I literally added you up on that
one
I was thinking I'm moving on without
mentioning but then I was like I'd be
funny we're in we're we found a good
space with it
oh
we're good
um
thank you baby
this situation was really scary because
my coping mechanisms weren't coping it
was the first time where I was like oh
[__] I actually don't know what to do
here
I eventually got to a point where I was
like this is not healthy this is not
good this is getting a really [__]
dark place right
of your own making
time to take a look in the mirror time
to take a look at the man in the mirror
oh
come on man boy in the mirror
The Fallout became deeply personal with
his younger brother who works as a model
in New York stopped talking to him
because of allegations that is really
really bad admitting that in this
article is a it was a little bit of a
mistake no it's jarring because they are
trying their best to remedy like all of
to launder his reputation but then his
brother I feel like he would be the most
credible like
witness in terms of like the people they
pulled they pulled the the kids who
didn't even want anything to do with it
like his own brother absolutely
communication with him if anybody knows
how many
100 percent
treading a well-worn post Scandal path
Charles spent the next few months mostly
offline doing a lot of self-reflection
and conferring with mental health
professionals and while a couple of
months may have seemed like a laughably
short time for a break who Charles
having no stage felt like an endless
punishment now I feel bad for him
I absolutely [__] hated it he said
ghost he's in poster jail
I am somebody who likes to be busy all
the time I love filming having nothing
to do drove me insane
[Applause]
that was hard man sounds like I mean it
does sound hellish
in the summer of 2021 Charles prepared a
comeback video a 30 minute YouTube
posted as an open conversation which
began with the acknowledgment that it
would be
ridiculously responsible to try to just
come back social media pretend like
nothing happened that being said who
wants to buy my makeup
it quickly became YouTube's most
disliked video of the week according to
Forbes although it's been watched more
than six million times his next post
about a tick tock cookie Trend was only
the third most disliked video of the
week so so that's good progress so
Charles kept posting driven by what I'd
armchair therapist diagnosed as a
compulsive need for online interactions
how about because it's his [__] job
and he makes millions of dollars doing
it
it's not just his brand it's been his
entire personality since grade school
yeah
as the only out gay kid in school in a
small town of Albany
Charles found his community of social
media he says
first on Tumblr then on Twitter and
Instagram we liked each other I'm not
reading this
his biggest mistake he now thinks we're
making himself available and recklessly
hitting on anyone he thought might be
showing him interest
okay first of all I'm pretty sure that
in a lot of these he was initiating okay
so you can stop that [__] right now
but that's not very interesting is it no
good point Colleen
his intention was never to pray on
minors
he says
[Laughter]
I believe him
he tried to explain this all in holding
myself accountable but it just didn't
come across his right he reflects I've
been [__] over by men for so many
times different times he's the he's the
victim right
right I understand man I understand
at this point I just want a [__]
boyfriend somebody says he's been crying
about this for years somebody that's
going to care for me somebody that will
let me sniff their armpit at any time of
the day and so a lot of times I just go
in uh into just talking with somebody
with rose-colored glasses dude shut the
[__] up
I still have to ask though why didn't
you just stick the actual adult dating
sites he tells me he previously had
accounts on Riot Tinder hinge and bubble
Bam Bam bumble
and while he did go on dates with people
he met there he ultimately felt too
exposed like anyone he swiped right on
was going to take screenshots we talked
about that quote
um
I know he's requirement yeah age
requirement yeah yeah also well
documented
yeah
I know you know and he knows that James
is on a mission to rehabilitate his
reputation
but and even though we've already
established he's very good at his job
I have to tell you that his regret
doesn't come across in person as the
opportunistic artif uh artifice so many
celebrities begrudgingly Wade through
shut the [__] up
it's more that he just seems Young
not that everybody in his position would
have the luxury of being perceived as
naive or guileless this comeback would
look a lot different if Charles were not
uh or not a physically beautiful white
man
okay in your opinion
what wow this is pathetic this person
should really be ashamed I think it's
it's a weird choice to describe him as
young when you've just described
the like power dynamic
you know what's young you have like a no
in this story he's not the young one in
the story he's the old oldie he's the
oldie he's the oldie and then here's the
final paragraph I sometimes wonder what
I would do if I blew up my professional
life in a public self-immolating where
and the answer is I Highway in a Surf
Shack on a remote island uh swaddling
myself in uh crafton's until my money
ran out but I know James I think I might
actually find out what that feels like I
can't wait to see you out there girl
self-fulfilling prophecy here see you on
that remote island girl the trait that
made him so famous in the first place
the Instinct an ability called
constantly seek out the light are the
same that have pushed him to endure the
backlash in pain
who wrote this
should I not look no
okay
that won't look man
I'm not gonna look
I'm just curious
I mean I have a right to know yeah no I
mean it's it's all partner put her name
on yeah listen nobody harass her I'm
genuinely curious do not [__] with this
girl sure you can share your feedback
about what you think about the article I
mean that's all fair games
is there a comment section that'd be
pretty fire
I think Cosmo posted it you're right
online though so like on on socials so
those comment sections are probably
oh she's like a little bit older lady it
seems like
I mean not like a inner twine okay now
that Line's even stranger to me this
comeback will be a lot different you
look like Elizabeth Holmes if Charles
were on a physically beautiful white man
I want to see Cosmo uh they do article
on uh OJ next about how he's a victim
man he is a beautiful man good looking
Gabrielle Bluestone is a journalist an
attorney from New York whose writing has
appeared in New York Times The
Washington Post
blah blah blah she's the Emmy nominated
executive producer wow of Netflix
Netflix fire and the associate Brews are
different flowers
she's winning she won awards
reaches a book
okay does she not look just like
Elizabeth Holmes in her picture
wearing a black turtleneck Elizabeth
Holmes I guess I the paranos lady their
news oh I see their demos not really
though but yeah so she's she's a bit
older that I find that interesting maybe
I can give her a pass just saying that
she's like kind of outside of the realm
of
well no wonder she's like yeah when I
ask all my Boomer ass colleagues they
don't know what he did like who the [__]
is James Charles
she looks younger here they don't even
know what YouTube is
what's a YouTube yeah what's computers
wait sorry but she looks younger in
these photos
okay whatever I'm not trying to
to dig in here guys don't do anything
dumb please don't harass her don't mess
with her I don't want that [__] love ya
that being said Cosmopolitan should be
this whole thing is just so embarrassing
man
my dude cheers my dude
well he wouldn't so James Charles
wouldn't say no homo
in response to the sound bite that you
played probably not right well what you
said cheers my dude no homo
I said love you love you love it cheers
my dude love you no homo that's the
quote Yeah so why y'all acting like
you're
gobsmacked I I I'm sorry I got lost okay
no worries
I'm with you thanks bro
love y'all
no homo
so there that is James Charles comeback
do we have any information about his new
makeup line they didn't really showcase
that I'm serious about it
yeah
yeah I don't see anything about it
painted this is what it is
now let's watch this
[Music]
um
the sisterland wrench
drop
say what sister land what's sisterland
sister land Ranch yes got it
it's just yeah the MJ stuff it takes me
a minute to process
what is he cooking here I don't know
it's like he's painting a masterpiece oh
it's a girl's face oh that makeup is a
mess boy you cannot go out like that
I'm sorry not go out like I'm sorry but
who's trying to do whatever you do you
[__] her whole [__] up dude that's
hilarious
like genuinely
so does this seem like an interesting
product I don't know what
um I can't really tell it just looks
like pigment
yeah
maybe it's just paint is it yeah you
know colored cream yeah they're all
different flavors
[Music]
like I'm not I
pigment paint
you don't get a easel no I like kind of
like mascara I like like lip gloss
that's a lot of makeup by the way the
way he's paying yes that's right James
is not the amount he's putting on that
easel and those tubes are small he's
Underground
you're gonna do great James
you're gonna do great things
[Applause]
and it looked like the whole number
Simpson makeup shotgun the answer is
yeah totally
[Music]
of paint is overwhelming you do have the
ability to use the apartment
they are literally formulated and made
for any level of artists okay so you're
selling face paint
I mean I could go do that at Knott's
Berry Farm
team started oh yeah clown pants yeah
it's for the ranch
awesome dude
this is gonna do really good different
shapes how to do different techniques
I don't know when this was shot I'll
give them the benefit of the doubt
he said he's been working on this for
four years so massive criticism online
has been
all right there it is we'll be following
closely my friend
actually we know someone who's already
used and vouching for it
uh
yeah looks really good wow that looks
good
yeah I hear they're using his paint at
the circus actually they're big fans of
it there
thank you
thank you sir all right now that that's
done should we do Cav cab or Boogie can
you can you quick cam just said I'm
sorry
let's take a look here
okay this is soon
just put out a new article they're on
the Spree Kevin space would like to be
on canceled please
please my Gabriella Bluestone the same
person Wow
Let's see the subtext too let's see uh
he grabbed the few kids dick big deal
right I mean we called the kids and they
didn't answer right right oh man they're
all dead right yes yeah all of his
accusers
Cosmopolitan tried to reach out to the
kids but uh they didn't answer what does
that mean suspicious
you should keep making this can you make
one about Bill Cosby sure or why not
keep them coming man
actually yeah no I was using this uh new
makeup line we did like with Teddy loves
this new makeup line he does like
dragons and lions and stuff
who is the target audience for face
paint children oh Teddy loves getting
his face oh no weird it's weird
let's do a poll Boogie or cavcov let's
let's do them do the Boogie thing we
talk about Cav cap last I see people
saying Cav cab that's the thing people
want to talk about calc
what topic you want Boogie we'll
probably do both we have time for both
uh we're getting we're almost at three
hours I don't know
yeah that's true
ah gosh I don't know which one
oh yeah the people have spoken Ryan cab
is at home like
don't worry cavi we'll get to it
will the Boogie one's shorter than the
Kev Cub one
can you keep making these for the rest
of the show cam they're so funny I'm on
the Bill Cosby one right now hell yeah
maybe a Louis CK one
I mean that article exists for Louis CK
and he have a profile when he did his
comeback really
I want to be uncanceled please
Harvey Weinstein Harvey Weinstein is
ready to be uncansled that's funny
all right let's [__] up it got it wasn't
an article there was a documentary that
was coming and actually just last month
that got canceled
oh wow in June I guess his request was
denied
request denied
okay so Boogie who's 48 10 years older
than me to be precise
okay
is dating a 20 year old who moved in 10
years older than you the way that you
have uh hazel eyes
I think Boogie has beautiful hazel eyes
to be totally cranked 20. I wasn't I was
asking but yeah yeah definitely and his
girlfriend I heard has hazel eyes too
beautiful stunning hazel eyes stunning
so apparently they started talking when
she was 19. now she's 20 and they
haven't been together long but she's
moving in with him
or they've been talking since October
um hold on breaking news coming out of
Cosmopolitan oh no way Bill Cosby would
like to be on cancel please they should
have checked their drinks duh Cosmic
Fulton
that's that is really bold
[Music]
Brave reporting that is really a bold
record R Kelly people are requesting
so album of tweets about the
relationship let's take a look
my one and only tweet about my age she's
an adult she's 20. what adult I think
we're maybe using bro I'm at this high
school girl that I was hot as [__]
tonight I genuinely didn't consider
myself an adult until I was like 30.
even now it's uh this question hard to
say it's questionable the label of adult
really becomes so silly when you become
a quo adult because you're you're still
just the same idiot adult
but I have kids you know so
yeah you're an adult Ethan I am thanks
for saying that bro that means a lot
you're welcome
do you feel like an adult
yeah good for you I think you're an
adult thanks man
thanks man
there's a few nod adults in here but I'm
not gonna name names oh [__]
bunch of [__] kids dude idiots
losers [__] young idiots it's not
your fault I felt like an adult when I
paid taxes last year right taxes [__]
you up that makes you feel like an adult
I mean I've been paying taxes but not
like this
why because you're making money like
they [__] me
but just because you're making more
money yeah
welcome to the big boys League baby what
are you complaining about you're making
more money well California is extra
sloppy yeah that too and LA City has a
tax too awesome I'm chilling Texas is
called like in half now I feel like I've
got a discount yeah I get big discount
like 20 discount
way less taxes here you pay 50 in Sweden
yeah because that's how much I pay here
because California and La have a tax and
then the federal tax yeah but you are
way richer than love and you were paying
around the same percent because tax is
Progressive so no I know but like even
like a way lower percentage okay now
because
the federal okay I guess the FED yeah
it'd be a lot lower yeah the payroll
still mostly Federal
well in my California you have property
tax which is State I don't even I don't
count that Sweden don't have property
tax I'm not including the property tax
no I consider that separate I'm just
talking about income yeah
but California has like a flat 10 I
thought
is that not right flat tax no
in the most Progressive state in America
flat tax
I don't know libertarian shirt out here
oh [__] Cosmopolitan just put on a new
article R Kelly would like to be
uncanceled no way
we all believe he can fly again here at
Cosmopolitan
okay did you guys really look into this
[Music]
I skimmed it over come on Gabrielle
did you not hear this recording
[Music]
so so wild
I mean that's the singer equivalent of
hey just send you all you have to do is
send me an armpit like this
all right let's get back to Buggy
can we do one on Hitler or something
let's just get even crazier with it [__]
you did pull pot let's go all out let's
uncancel pull putts you know we wasn't
picking up one more and then I'll get
too good what was that Aiden
about what
it was right okay we're gonna have to
unpack
about what
all right back to Boogie so she's an
adult she's 20. I'm older but look at me
man I am fat old and ugly as Sin
when an adult woman I get along with
wants to give it a shot I'm gonna do the
smart thing and give it a shot if you
can't handle that tell your therapist I
mean
what do you think about that statement
this little thing
this makes me feel
uncomfortable
this one's bad
this one's real bad we're in the bad
place I think we're gonna see him in
cosmopolitics in a few years
oh can we get one about bookie
sure
um but I mean okay
if he's like nobody's wants to be with
me but this tone hero girl
you guys might be moving a little fast
though
oh here's a boogie one let's see
a clip of me on the HP podcast going
around where I admitted to dating a 20
year old when I was 44. if you think
that's creepy keep in mind mentally and
emotionally I'm 14 so she was robbing
the cradle this is an older situation I
just I don't remember the context but
it's just well now he's older but they
say the same age
so he's
so he's two years older now
he's 48. oh he's 48 now yeah I thought
he was 50. 52 or 53. is that just
[__] that you're trying to make fun
of my age well you said you said he was
10 years older stop not funny 38 and
he's 48. I think it's funny
uh let's see the album yeah I'm sure
this will end well it's a fair comment
most relationships don't man but we'll
we will see
she wrote me on insta we talked about
our trauma in our past God
both were doing therapy around that time
and both worked to heal ourselves we
found out we were on the same path
together and one day she said she had
feelings we decided to explore that now
here we are
why is he why are you telling everybody
this
that's part of what makes it weird right
[Music]
maybe the fear of it getting out just
getting out of it I guess I think he's
bragging about it
could be both I think he's getting ahead
of it and that's what Zach said he's
bragging
you think it's braggadocian I think he's
like look I'm with a 20 year old
you know everyone made fun of me well he
has become friendly with keemstar since
he started hating me
and if kimster knows anything it's the
joys of dating a child
by child I mean
a legal adult a legal adult I met this
high school girl that I was hot as [__]
tonight right that's what I mean you
took the words out of my mouth
oh Boogie said this tweet in 21 Kim
keeps getting older but the 20 year old
girls stay the same age
personally I hope this is where Keem
learned the same lesson I did while it's
legal to date women that age it isn't a
great use of your time and has the
chance to be miserable for both you and
Ed do not recommend holy [__] dude
yeah
[Music]
that's so what changed Boogie what
changed is
he became friends with keemstar yeah
with Cam that's good
let's see uh he continues video games TV
shows music Love of Animals most
importantly we both survived a shitload
of trauma and came out grateful and
happy afterwards
okay
us reading comments on the internet
right now be like
be like what that's
it's a picture from
a father-daughter day out together I'm
sorry I mean like they're they're at the
Museum doing the wacky together that is
horrible I think they're actually he got
a selfie stick maybe he's got yeah he
has a selfie stick yeah selfie stick is
so short it's what's the point
maybe it's retracted it's a vlog it's
for vlogging it's a tripod you may as
well use it I did the same one in my
backpacks [__] you this selfie stick man
wait holy [__] Cosmopolitan is on this
whoa dude there's okay Larry Nazar
seriously that's [__] up
I actually would like to be on canceled
please he was a doctor at some of our
nation's greatest Olympians
after all
okay that is really miss that you're
missing the whole point of what happened
there Cosmopolitan and shame on you
didn't get beat up Impressions
11 times free that guy no no he was fine
apparently which um well good he lives
to be stabbed another yeah exactly he
must have he must have been in the arm
or something because I don't know how
you're getting stabbed it was a cell man
it was a cellmate holy [__] damn hey bro
that's what you get for
isn't that awesome like living with the
consequences of being like a prolific
prolific that guy is like evil oh I hope
he lives in fear every day for the rest
of his life
disgusting was it worth it bro
it's awesome [__]
what we stabbed twice in the neck twice
in the back and six times in the chest
okay how this [__] survive he's
the [__] 50 Cent of [__] yeah
he's a fighter one more time he's a
doctor he knows how to move his organs
and stuff
that's true oh you think you like
stitched himself up yeah he was like
like I'm a surgeon
I am a surgeon
yeah he's the worst what kind of
reaction were you hoping for somebody
asked you must have been anticipating
this kind of reaction criticism but not
the abuse and grooming [__] what would
the what
what would the criticism be yeah
if you get really specific probably
I don't know about B I don't know if
he's abusing her but it's definitely
like
I I can't see their chat logs but you
know probably but of course that's what
people are going to say you've been on
the internet long enough bro now you
just look stupid
but there's a whole bunch more let's see
Brantley
that's a name I haven't heard in a
minute Brantley Queen Brantley said
Boogie brags to them about how she was
an 18 year old virgin
Pearl approved
[Applause]
hold on this turns the whole world
upside down if Boogie pulled an
eight-year-old virgin that means he's of
high value male
no question no question
now this this is uh
this is Pearl's world and we're just
living in it
so Brantley quote tweeted it and said
you told us she was an 18 year old
virgin me Ken came and kid behind the
camp whoa so is she going after him
because if she is an eight-year-old
virgin then that that's definitely makes
it sound a lot worse
wait so he she's saying he's lying he's
lying she's she's saying
you gotta love that though he goes to
them talks about it and they just air
out his [__] immediately
that's how keemstar does it
why did she tweak this
maybe Kim is sour because Boogie
publicly said like he didn't make [__]
from that match he's actually oh he lost
money so he's in life ruining mode right
yeah he's ready to ruin Kim's life for
that or I mean vice versa
what I want to know is there's such an
age difference what what could they
possibly possibly be talking about that
is a great question
actually you know he said video games
that's what he said yeah
trauma like Lego red flags there at all
Legos yeah Legos that's a good points
Minecraft
glasses they both wear glasses it looks
like fortnite Beau blacks King of the
show says boogie sent him proof that
she's 20. okay who tweeted from is this
from his main or um as his main but I
love the king of the show not even
friend just King of the show
uh what the [__] according to Brantley
Boogie's new girlfriend is 18. update
Boogie sent me proof that she's indeed
born in 2003. I turned 20 earlier this
year damn what was the name of boby's
Alt
oh good question
yeah
oh man
Vlog Boogie uploaded of her is giving us
weird vibes
here's our boy should we watch the whole
thing I mean I usually get into this
kind of stuff
I let's watch it all it's gonna be good
okay I tried
I knocked out so fast I I couldn't so
you're with me now then that's fine
because I watched all of it yeah you're
with me now brother roll it
we've been looking okay chill came I'm
going to roll it
yeah
now for a couple of weeks right right
what do you think are you having fun
and you've just did you make any friends
this Summer that you are
[Laughter]
can you turn it up a little bit for me
yeah it's kind of quiet
are ready to let the internet know
are you nervous
I
I'm more excited and nervous yeah so I
did post some photos to Twitter last
night
um and the reaction has been interesting
yeah I mean the people that are happy
for us are very happy for us and I think
that's great
um there's people who are like cautious
because I mean you know you should
always be cautious in any new
relationship but I don't think they
realize that we've been talking
started off as friends careful careful
how you say how long you've been talking
right it's not a huge window
or that's okay
we've been talking for two I mean two
months two yeah I mean two months
Chad had a good suggestion they said
that maybe they talk about like he could
tell her what 911 was like because she
wasn't born yet oh yeah first-hand
account not many of us left
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's like the Holocaust Survivors where
our numbers are dwindling
a good couple months ago like hey yeah
nine months I think it was October right
it was it was in October and we got to
know each other we've been very careful
about it we were doing the long distance
thing yeah we've been very careful about
it hard wasn't that hard
and you wrote me on
a social media platform I think it's one
of the major three but I don't
necessarily want to dox her today I
don't anybody blowing up her socials
just why saying which one she messaged
you on I know which one it was Snapchat
um
it always goes down on Snapchat no I
thought didn't he tweet and say that he
met her on Instagram yeah I'm kidding
okay because Snapchat is like yeah that
is the groomer Predators this is audio
in this angle makes it seem I'm sorry
like he's driving like the bang bus or
something yeah it is
it's giving me adult film vibes
Bang Bus
it's giving me dad on the way home from
school I heard that do you think in his
love making the the he goes the the
Francis voice like he's so beautiful
right now well remember when he told us
and I'm I'm just recalling what he told
us
that was insane you know what I'm not
gonna go I'm not even gonna
yeah
and we talked about
his life man being hard right life dude
yeah
we just talk about life being hard yeah
yeah I could have so much it sounds
upbeat so much homework
fine yeah I hate homework man I hate
finals number two pencils man you know
you know the end of the semester is
coming up and it's just always a Hustle
did you hate the scantrons filling out
the bubbles [__] scantrons bro
you know you have your calculator
charger you've gone through it well
neither of you I got to buy myself a new
ts80 or whatever it's called
and remember sweetheart don't put Tetris
on it donut but put games on your
calculator you're gonna get in trouble
yeah yeah we're able to relate
and we bonded over that
um
and I think I've definitely done my best
healing in the last
year especially in the last eight months
what's eight months ago he's been
feeling hard in the last uh he's been
healing hard his region stat is really
high
he's being very particular about
maybe he has I don't know I don't know
yeah maybe he just is very knowledgeable
about it he knows all every single one
do you think um
do you think they play Roblox together
or no
maybe definitely fortnight
for it night Fortnight uh I mean
obviously I did some psychedelics and
that hope
cool
actually I would like to hear more about
that yeah
um obviously I uh but I think you've
been a big part of it I think I know a
lot of people tell me I don't know on my
channel that
I seem happier
and duh
because I am yeah yeah and you seem
really happy no you make me very happy
yeah
so what are the rules you seem really
happy
you seem really really happy
and I don't want to see that slip
I don't know a little weird we decided
we're gonna do it do you want to be
the girl behind the camera do you want
to be in front of the camera how do you
want to do this
that is [__] what's the POV on this
[__] you want to be the girl behind the
camera in front of the camera oh my gosh
that is oh yeah so let's listen with
this music it'll uh definitely add a new
flavor
yeah Rogers Aquatic Center I try to come
out here at least it's crazy a couple
times this summer yeah this is my first
time coming out with somebody
dough are you excited I'm very excited
are you gonna do the big slides oh yeah
that's very much like talking to your
toddler
you want to do the big slides you're
coming out to the water park with me no
no no no no no are you doing the big
slides with me sweetie
you like The Lazy River
oh
[Music]
okay sweetheart let's stop at the locker
really fast so we can put our stuff and
then we can go to the slide okay
we can get you we can get you souvenirs
on the way out okay sweetheart
yeah are you gonna do the Lazy River
with me oh he did say that yeah he does
he gets worse yeah
we're gonna do the Lazy River together
[Music]
make sure to put on sunscreen okay
sweetie
I am are you just gonna sit in a beach
chair and look pretty yes
there you go nice
[__] I love my little more so
so no what the hell I didn't mean to
pause on that oh my God I just like they
dip her in the lounge and Boogie just
doing the laser River solo
[Music]
send me a new one for the Mortal Kombat
nothing it says summer to me like a
water park
and this is the nicest one in the area
don't get me wrong I'd rather be like
Silver Dollar City thing you know
Branson but for local this is great
you're not supposed to do that in your
face
[Music]
not for your face Boogie wait are you
really not supposed to well yeah you
know you shouldn't put this one you're
not supposed to spray your face I do
that all the time
right I don't think you're supposed to
breathe aerosol sunscreen I think I
think he was putting it on his teeth so
these teeth
that's brutal Maybe
they're beautiful it's crazy the way
he's doing that yeah don't breathe
aerosol sunscreen really I think I don't
think I'm pretty sure I mean everyone's
always said that it says on the bottle
do not use on face and big bold capital
I always use specific face sunscreen I
don't think there's face I mean it's not
good to breathe aerosol stuff but I
don't think that's why they say not to
put it on your face I don't want the
insides of my nose burned dealer dude I
I think it's probably fine I'm just
kidding
but it's probably just so you don't get
irritated get in your eyes and [__] it's
just a disclaimer
can aerosol sunscreen cause lung cancer
they can be irritating to your lungs if
inhaled never spray sunscreen directly
at your face
okay it's just about breathing it
smells good no big deal
your lungs won't get sunburned yeah good
smart
I burn so bad dude oh my God you can
actually get my back for me yay
you ready yeah I got you
yeah oh my god oh there's jokes in my
mind right now
you
can I let me type this I probably
shouldn't because I'm trying to be
respectful in good ways okay [__] it do
it no seven baby
yeah
I knew what you were gonna say I called
it I won't say it though right it's
funny April said it was so funny no I I
know
oh I spelled that wrong
everyone knows what we were gonna say
yeah maybe you guys just write it
yourselves in your head yeah imagine me
saying it
let me see if the chat understands
let's move on
quick probably not going to burn
T rocks yeah here's how you know I'm
basically a kid
so fun to me
you are so innocent he's so childlike
and innocent at our
it's fun to me
[Laughter]
he did lose a lot of weight like being
real he yeah he does look good yeah
grandpa is feeling a little frisky you
know and I do hope that he is able to
continue losing weight you know that
would be incredible yeah
I love weight loss uh stories so
inspiring
I always like to make it a surprise so
true
Lazy River here we go
oh no
so cold it's so cold
I don't know why it's funny
yeah there's one snagit
[__] you
there too his teeth look like they got
adjusted they look more proportional
than when you first got them
yeah um they look like they may shift
the white balance a little bit but they
look great
oh he's so cool
oh
[Music]
he's by himself
he's by himself right now interesting
okay so we can enjoy this moment
she wanted to do the slides and that he
wanted to do the Lazy River they didn't
they couldn't do it together they just
split up well he probably can't do this
slide yeah but do you find it a little
funny that she's like I'm I'm gonna go
do this Slide by myself and not hang out
with you fun bye Dad I'll meet you as a
kid's slide let's meet up and we'll meet
up at lunch okay at 12 o'clock oh yeah I
want to make friends yeah here's 12 okay
sweetheart if you need to buy a water or
a Coke I mean 12 isn't enough
okay fine here's 20.
for a Coke
12's not enough dad oh my goodness hi I
found you
occurring huh
[Music]
this is giving me prices
beautiful summer day honest scent
gorgeous wow
that's pretty good I mean that was
decent form yeah if you look back to
where he was when he first did that
splash I mean he definitely come a long
way in terms of what he can do
physically yeah this is awesome
that's not bad that is not bad form
really isn't
it crazy shots
yeah it looks like Jesus right here it's
a callback to one of his early viz
except for his love it's symbolic right
so I could tell yeah what makes you
nervous about the water park uh I'm not
too many people person yeah I respect
that yeah so it's a good thing we're
going to a bunch of conventions this
week huh oh yeah because we're going to
Greenville South Carolina uh that's this
weekend then we're going to St Louis in
a couple of weeks and then Rancho
palooza in Dallas Texas on August 16th
if you want to come and meet us we will
be there
but now I want to do something for you
darling
you should get something fancy to eat
are you on a nice meal I do
I know just the place
KFC
we getting KFC bowls tonight baby
McDonald's oh
he did it he did the job no get a frog
have a fry nothing for her
oh you like you like McDonald's yep I
got you two cheeseburgers
because I know how to spoil a woman yes
you do babe
Okay so
in short I'll say this
[Music]
I don't think Boogie has the best track
record with relationships I know he had
a very tumultu tumultuous and contested
uh you know
uh uh divorce with his wife
and uh she was his age so I just hope
that first of all no Hate to this 20
year old I mean she's done nothing you
know what I mean she's just living her
life and doing her thing
so I'm not I got no hate my hard fur I
don't give her any [__] you know I just
hope that Boogie is
not gonna ruin her life forever just
because he I know he can be
a little
I think in his personal relationships
from what I understand can be pretty
heavy duty
so and that's not and that is not a play
on words that was purely purely
unintentional
[Music]
I swear to God that was I was just pure
I believe you actually he loves hard
he even says look at you think it's
skinny now look what happens I didn't
say anything about his way
congratulating him
show up
sell out you fat sell out
um I know you guys have any thoughts I
just I just hope that she doesn't come
out of this too scarred genuinely
like there's gonna be some damage here
it's just a matter of how much yeah
you know
yeah and that's all I have to say about
that
do you see the cosmo article
oh [__] Cosmo already about this
oh my God that was fast
where yo Cosmopolitan wrote an article
Boogie would like to be uncanceled
I don't know if he's fully canceled but
it's pretty bizarre and bad vibe to be
honest oh so they couldn't even absolve
it just they're not even sure what's
going on here oh man that's tough that's
tough
maybe they'll get married
you never know
do you
why is your character not moving where's
your sticks
Mr Beast why are you here oh he endorses
it he's doing the Mr Beef there oh wow
yeah it doesn't work
if you're just in front of Bass Pro Shop
no
his girlfriend took a Bass Pro Shop okay
I'll buy it ladies and gentlemen on
YouTube
I was getting to the power you know I
can't resist a good bass pro shop moment
yeah this is a nice convergence and
Desi's here
hi and this is our last night at home
for a little while we are actually
heading out on the road Southeast Game
Exchange
Greenville South Carolina come see us
get on with it bro
oh look at this microwave
oh what the bro what the [__] is that
his is that his apartment
you guys got a lot of microwaves that's
like Jeffrey Dahmer's microwave but did
you see the coffee yeah
what's going on in there oh gross but
did you see this slimy coffee maybe I
just know is it slimy yeah
oh it's called Coco okay it's just hot
cocoa it looks like sludge yeah doesn't
it
dude can you please clean your microwave
that was like a lot to handle although
something tells me that microwave is not
the worst
cleaning crime going on in that house on
her first night here Chelsea relax
oh hi there hi you were supposed to come
in yeah
he's making that for her when she wakes
up that's that's nice that is sweet I'm
not looking that's not the first
beverage I want in the morning
personally I would
I don't know
maybe it's because I'm 22. you're older
she's young I mean you're younger she's
younger you can start your day like that
yeah if I started my day with that I
guarantee I would be done my day would
be ruined
sorry I didn't mean to I was surprising
with Coco
also my roommate is making
Strawberry Shortcake for last night here
and apparently
a meat pie
oh
wait what uh wait okay hold the phone he
had me for a second that meat has not
has been sitting there for a really long
time just want to take some pictures
I would not eat that
that does look very good there but I
promise it'll look a lot better instead
of a pie okay since morning clothes are
so big I have a system
did I just leave my clothes in my trunk
in a big box like this
if you're driving everywhere you don't
have to bring your clothes in every
single time at a hotel just leave them
in the trunk bring in the clothes you
need
that's what I do
because I'm fat and lazy and my clothes
are the size of a tent
also I don't know if I've ever showed
you guys this
when you get old and you get bro you
don't have to show us all this it's just
like sad
here's my dirty microwave here's the 20
pill boxes I have to take here's the
laundry which I'm too lazy to take care
of like can you just put your best foot
forward please
Kali man
and then the meat pie here's the [__]
meat pie that we're eating for dinner
what is that bro
killing me man
this is what your life looks like we got
a Gabapentin in here and heart pills in
here a muscle relaxer and multivitamin
and
I'm gonna take this with you everywhere
you go
stay I mean not to be rude but
everybody's pill bottle probably
doesn't look that intense
because he said this is what your pill
bottle will look like
right when yeah but he's 48.
okay thank you be healthy take care of
yourselves learn from my mistakes okay
fair good advice that's my diet Mountain
Dew
I am definitely going to split that
cocoa with her though yeah so it's been
about 48 hour I I'll be honest babe I
made it for me
since we went live
with our relationship and uh you know
obviously we click baited it a little
bit with the moving in and all the stuff
it has been an interesting 48 hours I'm
not gonna lie uh first off so many of
you have been supportive of my fans have
always been supportive the people that
are my ride and dies God bless you I
love you you make everything possible
there are people out there who have
always disliked me and this is
definitely something they've used as you
know they dislike me and then there's
some Fair criticisms about the age Gap
and things along that lines and I get it
I respect it I understand it but know
that everybody's being really careful
here she's being very careful with me
I'm being very careful with her is she
being careful about
what does that mean dude
and no one's gonna get hurt at least
you're not being careful with that meat
that's been sitting out there for 20
hours
definitely gonna be having diarrhea
any more than anyone gets hurt in a
normal relationship so God bless you for
your concern people say my pillbox is
worse than I'm 24. okay I take back the
pillbox comment I take a lot of pills
but I'm mentally ill I take a lot of
pills too I'll be honest I have four
pills of mine so you know well you gotta
start vlogging that [__]
you gotta start vlogging it oh yeah I
got a shot yeah here's my pill box guys
look get a load of this [__] but yeah
all my pills are for
um
my various mental illnesses I don't know
if they call it illness depression
anxiety
oh then some of them are for um
you guys know what I take yeah yeah I
take Wellbutrin Lexapro
and
omeprazole
every morning baby my personal is
[__] sick dude do you take a map
that's a stomach thing right yeah yeah
for heartburn yeah take it not
prescription I take it every now and
then when it's bad oh yeah you don't
need it it's over the counter you can
buy a shitload on Amazon yeah no it's
very good when I feel upset
um that drug literally is life-saving
like oh my God [__] you
do it all day we're just gonna find her
happiness and someone said I like his
beard I agree facial hair looks pretty
on point well kept uh I hope you find
your happiness too
why are we
what bro don't hit me is that how you
hit her bro don't hit me I hope you find
your happiness too
why does Bass Pro Shop have a pyramid
that's like
for the Pharaohs Mecca
did slaves build their pyramid shop
worshipers
what
we're at the Bass Pro Shop to get Bass
you gotta take it you got to take a bath
with you when you enter Tennessee is it
your first time in Tennessee right you
always have to have a bass with you
trust me they have really good bass in
here
look at that balcony up there yo I
didn't not realize that they're that big
of a deal they have their own [__]
pyramids with like an observation deck
at the top
we were just there at the pyramid oh
yeah it's sick
Disneyland in there awesome it's in
Memphis what are you doing the pyramid
well the whole thing is a store and it's
also a hotel oh you can stay there and
the hotel apparently is like super nice
if you look at pictures it's like really
nice okay
um there's a lake in there okay there's
lots of live animals okay uh a lot of
restaurants a gigantic like aquarium
it's fun okay cool it's fun as [__] yeah
that sounds cool we should go
I'm down
what is this meme should I open this
oh what I sent yeah it just it was
giving me the Vibes of uh Planes Trains
automobiles this the scene right here
this is gonna be Boogie when he watches
us back you want to hurt me go right
ahead if I make you feel any better
I'm an easy target yeah you're right I
talk too much I also listen too much it
could be a cold-hearted cynic like you
but I don't like to hurt people's
feelings well you think what you want
about me I'm not changing I like I like
me my wife likes me my customers like me
because I'm the real article you see
what you get
this is a meme
this is Spot On Boogie it's a popular
scene from the movie I don't know very
specific meme
a lot of words perfectly there's a lot
of words
aren't you afraid of heights you're
terrified you going up there with me
yeah you're going up there with me
I'm just gonna be honest with you you
picked the wrong dude if you're afraid
of heights I'm gonna take you on every
roller coaster
every ferris wheel
you name it you're in trouble that's
great man that's a really good that's
awesome
I'm definitely afraid of heights okay
then I'm gonna [__] exploit your
fears
um
I have never been in here and I've
always wanted to come
and I thought this is a good excuse but
look at how big this place is I mean it
looks big from the highway but good Lord
it's huge
[Music]
it already has
a hotel in it as well as just wow just
wowie wow wow so this is the spot oh
shoot we didn't have a shooting gallery
here you know I'm crazy for these now
I'm just now this is just an ad for Bass
Pro Shop Superstore
the Great Pyramid
let's see if you get something
[Music]
loser oh
all right this video sucks oh hell yeah
I mean we don't always get it
[Music]
real old doorsy type out
all right
times this wasn't that good the second
one really
these are very very good though
if I can look at these again
didn't Boogie make a tweet
um recently after coming out with his
relationship he said the thing about 20
year old girls is that I get I get older
but they stay the same age he said that
about himself
I think you're saying about your friends
the one he was making what was the key
one you're the key one no he made it
about himself too recently I think all
right
and he says uh personally I hope this is
where Keem learned the same lesson I did
while it's legal to date women that age
it isn't a great use of your time and
has a chance to be miserable for both
you in the end do not recommend awesome
well anyway I I hope that uh she ends up
okay out of this you know that's it
there you go you know
get your happiness
get whatever you should come on
okay so actually the hotel room does
look really good actually
yeah if you look over here wow yeah the
bed looks super luxurious that's a
kitschy but it's nice nice armchair
fireplace oh look at the look at the um
Chandelier super nice
um
nice Irish ceilings yeah
super nice Bulletproof
yeah beautiful
um
actually doing a few go back at the ski
uh the skiing uh the shooting game
it looks really fun if you check out the
um
oh yeah the rifle area oh fun for all
ages
though
foreign
I think we're being too hard on Boogie
Maybe
I don't know it's
yeah
um yeah better or is this creepier oh
God he posted this when did he post this
July 15.
why this what do you why is this angle
happening right now
so is this better okay that is straight
up your daughter in your lap
like I'm sorry that's just what it is
what was on the agenda tonight
buggy why are you doing this why are you
posting this [__] look at this face why
don't you take a seat right over there
just don't post as much
[Music]
I'm Chris Hanson with Dateline NBC
you know
this is what I see
this is what I see yeah
[Music]
this is from Chad just touched up the
photo a little bit
oh
yeah
all right well we wish you the best
get out there and live your best life
all right well we have Cav kevleff but I
think it's time to go how long we've
been going or yeah uh three hours 24
minutes and 26 seconds okay
let me look just at one quick video oh
my God damn it just a little preview
now we don't know if he made this but
like obviously I think it's pretty safe
to assume he did because who else would
[__] make this
but still it's just an assumption an
adoring fan he's got fans yeah
what's this supposed to say
a YouTube channel okay we don't know
that he made this let's let's say that
exclusively of videos people of people
saying nice things about him
that's description apparently is pretty
funny too
and our pursuit of greatness it's
important to remember that if people
aren't criticizing or doubting us we
haven't truly pushed the boundaries or
taken risks uh-huh
I can say this much as a SEO agent I
have done similar things for
for people I would say before
it's likely if it wasn't him he was
involved in the creation of it
um allegedly I don't know right could
have been one of his many fans as Dan
said many many fans whether we aim to
revolutionize our field or make
game-chasing decisions failure is
inevitable especially with you
I love that failure is inevitable Ryan
Kavanaugh
that's awesome embracing failure is a
sign that we've tried and explored our
full potential it's essential to realize
that
the opinion of strangers or passing
acquaintances don't Define us what truly
matters is our own self-perception and
the opinion of our loved ones by letting
go of others what the [__] dude what are
you saying bro it's just a bunch of
videos of people saying nice things
about you for no reason
all right
which one should we hit up first Mr
Beast you're kind of killing the vibe
here
I think I gotta turn off Beast for this
no I I can't see what the [__] it's just
here right uh yeah
Mr Beast YouTube Mr beastiality that's
[__] up that's not what it's called
Mr bestiality that's inappropriate not
want the exceptions
that's just not appropriate at all [__]
my dog can I under can I just turn it
off I have to remove it I [__] it you're
gone Mr beastiality and shame on you by
the way before you did to all those
animals
all right let's see let's see Woody
Harrelson talking about working with
Ryan Kavanaugh okay so this is not a
public video like what the [__] hi I'd
like to congratulate you Ryan my brother
Cameo Woody what the [__] I'm just gonna
say yeah it sounds like a cameo
dude what is it you did
there's a gun off camera making him do
this and the rest to you at relativity
for 10 years I mean this is an
incredible awe-inspiring uh
time-consuming thing it took a decade
but I gotta say you guys you really have
some great stuff and I I got the
opportunity to do two films with you uh
free birds and Out of the Furnace Free
Birds is uh
by the way he's talking about this is
supposed to be like a decade old or more
super old like yeah I can see people are
really they're really riding for you bro
by the way the comments are off which
makes me believe even more that he's
involved in this yeah but again I'm
alleging that numbers on
US Air
a lot of people have seen it and
hey by the way can you give me a call
Ryan because I got like just I got I got
it I got a couple of scripts I need to
get nothing big you know 10 to 12 maybe
15 range and uh I really see myself
directing you know let's see myself this
is straight up a personal video and I
feel like he shouldn't have posted this
publicly if it was him
wait yeah it says about me he barely
mentioned Ryan
oh he says about me well in the
description there's a link to that
comedic has ever styled talks about
working with Ryan Kavanaugh Ryan just as
Ryan in in the description of the
YouTube channel oh okay
[Music]
thought I'd be sitting in the chair all
day
awesome bro that one's really good funny
talented filmmaker talk relativity
this is sad [__] how would you rate
relativity bro this [__] is so old
uh all right what's up guys hey
relativity
they really asked all these people to
make videos
Ryan Kavanaugh there are two there
there's like what's the chances that
somebody sourced all these yeah no
you're you're 99 right in my opinion I
mean allegedly you know who knows who
knows yeah maybe somebody sourced all
these private videos sent to Ryan
Kavanaugh
and made a compilation and put them all
on YouTube
everybody
oh [__] hi everyone wait are we
listening to copyrighted music yeah the
underneath the bed might not be good to
keep playing there's Neon Trees here
Casey Affleck here in the United States
of America and where where's he been out
here in Hollywood did he get canceled
who won an Oscar yeah
yeah that's what he wanted
Ryan's a good guy he's humble
check out his Wikipedia page if you want
to learn more about him oh yeah he had
sa claims
oh he did yeah okay
you settled two women's civil suits in
2010. here's Michael bubble was this
[__] I know
Michael bubble bubble here he is
joking with Ryan this is stunning he was
joking with Michael bubble
adjectives to describe Ryan um
good good kind
ugly
pathetic insecure
that's total [__] Mess Sloppy it's
like a HD incompetent constantly creepy
creepy constantly damp for some reason I
would love if they got Natalie Portman
to do one of these for him
Ryan was a force of nature yeah
he didn't he did not wait he totally
just gives them a script then sure he's
telling everyone to say he's a force to
Nature I'll argue that was originally
possibly wine screen Weinstein's script
and then he just passed that along
can you imagine he's being like okay now
call me a force of nature
try again bubble but nicer [__] second
take bubble
don't [__] up
maybe the best word to describe him is
he's my friend oh my God
this performance
you're selling it too hard hey Dan's
right he's reading the paper oh it won't
be a day that goes by though I don't
miss him I can't believe he's gone wait
thank you
[Music]
what
okay
let's just move on I don't know just for
fun I missed it no it wasn't just for
fun I just covering my basement oh okay
so I'm gonna watch it back because I
feel like he's not that potentially
maybe it's not worse let me listen well
I mean whatever yeah no we're just
celebrating our 10th anniversary oh
that's really good news
oh God right because
that's great you and a lot of other
people actually
he owes everyone around town money man
this is 10 years congratulations why
not bubble
get that man in the movies
relativity media boy can act
who knew
dude these are awesome Seacrest talks
Kavanaugh oh
congratulations Ryan and the entire team
at relativity on an incredible decade of
creativity all of this was for some like
luncheon that they had for the 10-year
anniversary this is so sad yeah what are
the chances the button screen was the
bull
what's his name Brad Brad the bull yeah
he was the be right back button
what button the button when you hit the
button you know it just randomly
shuffles through like yeah do we have a
brad the ball on I guess yeah landed on
that one did he really yeah nice that's
[__] funny
making great listening that was a badly
timed button I don't know listen the
button is the button okay
the bubble is the bubble and I hit the
button I buttoned the bubble
bubble entertainment so if that's what
you did for the first 10 years
Secrets Don't make me mad what's gonna
happen the next ten I'll tell you Ryan
because they're bad for the future
bankruptcy uh lying about uh his one of
his Executives committing uh sexual
harassment to avoid paying him his
Severance
allegedly allegedly and then also him
him emailing Natalie Portman really
creepy weird stuff uh being disgraced by
the entire media you know uh almost sued
he was sued for running a Ponzi scheme
later retracted it was retracted burning
an enormous amount of money on a uh
d-tier social media platform that's
flipped oh yeah house trailer boxing
going
yeah the next seniors are great
yeah it was retracted so I want to say
that
the Variety article yeah so
um go ahead that full anniversary video
is on um
on that Variety article I [__] love
the yellow teeth man
boy you could eat a brush dude
wait zoom out there you go uh Ryan
Kavanaugh would like to be on Council
please he's a force in nature that's
true I've heard that about him
yo
brush your teeth bro right
um I have a pretty interesting cap
update that I just stumbled upon tell me
everything I just Googled triller and
went to news to see
if there's anything recent in two days
ago oh wow an article
uh I guess Trump just recently uh
released some Financial disclosure stuff
wait what and revealed that His Highest
speaking fi it's speaking fee by far was
when he did that commentary on a triller
boxing event you remember that yep they
paid him 2.5 million dollars what a
[__] idiot no wonder you're the worst
business in your life like you nobody
should let you anywhere near the reins
of a company or a checkbook for that
matter
and that that event I guess was a
massive Financial uh failure in general
and it says with the massive Financial
losses of the event Trump's 2.5 million
payout didn't seem like a very
successful hosting for triller you know
what's funny you could say that Ryan
alleges in the defamation lawsuit that
because of our coverage of him he lost
he was like removed from the board and
and uh lost all these opportunities with
trailer are you sure it wasn't the fact
that you like lost hundreds of millions
of dollars and are literally horrible
everything you do turns to [__] yeah
like you are literally like the Midas is
the Midas
inverse minus yeah I'm trying to think
like
everything you turn touch just turns
I might as well not touch nice
yeah
awesome
Trump made a billion dollars last year
holy [__]
but it says took home over a billion
dollars
oh after his term ended
not surprised
he's definitely milking that [__] for
every goddamn Cent Ryan Kevin Ryan love
you buddy
oh [__] dude this is pathetic this is
actually so pathetic that somebody did
this
whoever it was
you know
uh Harry is given a speech
oh this is the one where he joked uh
sorry too much wine alternator
I think I think I recognized the
background you take definitely looks
like this year
they would produce her Awards
that'd be awesome if he cut it all out
there he is I mean he looks like he's a
rough night
thank you listen I don't know but based
on his history he's gonna say something
really dumb
this moment from oops Yeah heavy
awardness what a [__] up God is trashed
you're putting it on the ground oh my
God God he's so bad at everything
idiot loser that's what it is to fail up
to have a Rich Dad [__] buffoon
[__] loser idiot
I don't mean to put it on the floor I'll
pick it up right after
um no one's laughing
not funny he uploaded this or I mean
somebody uploaded this
holy [__]
you are a disaster
nature dude he's a force of something
this moment for me
is an honor Beyond an honor
I think back to my what's an honor
Beyond an honor Super Saiyan honor a
super honor this honor has gone Super
Saiyan my friend God uh ssj God S3 G7
E7 boy
God he's so wet that's what I'm seeing
always it's yours uh you know like last
year
um just kidding okay another bomb joke I
think back to my teenage years uh you
know like last year
um just kidding
holy [__] bro you are like you're like a
black hole of Charisma oh my God like
not only does all the energy get sucked
out you make everyone around you feel
more hateable and less charismatic like
you were basically ruining this award
show yeah
uh you know like last year
um just kidding
um crickets bro that was a quiet room
why would somebody upload this
when I think back to that moment when I
first came into the business I remember
I I picked up a trade Magazine and there
was a picture of Ron Meyer on the front
and I opened it and the article
explained that Ron was the guy who had
become one of the most powerful men in
the business he was responsible for a
paradigm shift in Hollywood and a shift
that would change our business forever
most importantly he did it with what
everyone referred to as tough but fair
negotiating skills
I remember reading the article and
thinking that's how I want to be
I want to make a change in the business
I do it being tough but fair today was
it people always go he must be like a
great salesman or he raises money I
don't know how he's so that would imply
he's charismatic or something yeah I
feel like people just want to leave
whatever room he's in
maybe that's part of the charm they go
yeah yeah just I'll sign just let's do
it okay to make this meeting end right
to have this man it's like a false
confession that's forced after like 12
hours yeah just let me out please Ron
Meyer presenting me with producer of the
year is a feeling I I can't put in words
I cannot thank Ron enough for his
continued support guidance mentorship
not to mention his tough but fair
negotiating skills although I could use
a little less stuff
crickets brother when I start bro you
are the cricket delivered you're the
king of crickets yeah
started in this business you know I was
I was just the money guy
I used to tell this story as a joke but
it's true when I first got in the
business with the studios I I was
basically told thanks for the [__]
money now leave so he had he's what he's
saying is I've started as the money guy
where'd your money come from how are you
feeling upward so much dude
I know his dad is that we his dad was
that was very wealthy yeah
although and correct me if I'm wrong I
remember reading something about his dad
like forging a fake
art piece I
according to I'd have to go back and
look I don't remember inquiring to
Insider relativity media CEO's father
will pay damages for selling a fake
Picasso that's crazy that's alleged by
and I don't know if it's true that's
just what Insider wrote correct is there
any updates on that article that I need
to be aware of did he did he retract the
the police retract was the lawsuit
retracted
wow his dad is a could you call that
being a con man I don't know
it might have been done in time
unintentional unintentionally perhaps
yeah maybe it was done unintentionally
not seeing any retractions so read that
title one more time just to get beat for
clarity relativity media CEO's father
will pay damages for selling a fake
Picasso and what's the name of the paper
uh Insider magazine they allege that I
don't know what happened
Business Insider to be Business Insider
wrote that article with that headline
what was it again I forget
go ahead uh relativity media CEOs father
will pay damages for selling a fake
Picasso right yeah
and that's not us alleging that
that was some reporter
oh that's crazy best but
clearly misunderstood he said something
else I just sorry just played my own
stream
thanks for the [__] money now leave
They're laughing because it's true when
I um did our second deal and they saw
maybe we were here to stay it was thanks
for the [__] money you can stay but
don't talk
today I'm I'm proud to say that our
passion for the creative process our
persistence and results
have earned us our seat at the creative
table and our partners have graciously
embraced us within that process
today we're in the very literally
disgraced
a fortunate position of making a lot of
movies
we are and we continue to be passionate
about the stories we bring to life we
approach boring
guys if you want to learn more about
Ryan Cavanaugh because he is a public
figure and he's very interesting go
ahead into the search bar
type Ryan Kavanaugh
into the search bar
Google it his name so you're searching
for his name Ryan Kavanaugh and scroll
down
here it is does Ryan comment look like
Harvard Weinstein click that link
and here you will find a lot of helpful
information uh to clear up
this big problem happening in the public
he looks like Harvey Weinstein and I
want to make it clear you know that
they're two different people so go ahead
spend some time here
few minutes at least right and uh a
couple of minutes here familiarize
yourself with the with the uh isn't that
it Ryan Cavanaugh is a force of nature
yeah just familiarize yourself with
everything
he did donate a million dollars to
Habitat for Humanity they never gave
them or you gave them 30 000 actually in
the end and after a whole pressure was
gone yeah it's all here
yeah
thank you Ryan
well I find that YouTube channel was
really informative
I like the part where bubble said he
died
bubble did a good job with that part
yeah
there it is a big scene all right guys
we've been going too long I get I have
too much fun here you know one thing
leads to another
bada bing bada boom
what was the headline I didn't you have
it open I forgot already
um yeah let me let me go back real quick
I forget it was something about his dad
uh yeah let's see just for clarity
because I
it's important to be accurate when
you're talking about stuff like this
right uh relativity media CEOs father
will pay damages for selling a fake
Picasso do we know that relativity CEO
is Ryan Kavanaugh do we know that's
referring to him yeah it does say his
name yeah okay there's another article
yeah there's more there's multiple
articles yeah for New York Times has one
so his dad was he was it a crime or was
it a lawsuit I let's
hold on I just want to clarify this
maybe what was the title again the title
relativities media CEO's father will pay
damages okay damages so it was like a
civil case it sounds like okay
something about a fake Picasso
allegedly I don't know
what the [__] do I know shout out
Michael bubble though
and thank you to all of our lovely
audience members I love you guys I'm
happy to be here it's Monday let's go
it's Monday baby
thank you everybody we had great
viewership numbers I'm just I'm so nice
by the way we're H3 2.9 again H 2.9
let's go
which is awesome nice to see you thank
you guys and uh we'll be back members I
will see you tomorrow
um Wednesday we'll be back for doing our
normal show having too much fun guys
it's uh H3 podcasts we're here
[Music]
thank you